Was?
Developers, Developers, Developers.
Developers, Developers.
Windows 11 ist Spyware.
Habe Windows Reverse Eng.
Das ist der Teufel.
Freue mich auf deine Worte dazu.
Also, ich glaube, man muss Windows nicht Reverse Engenieren, um zu wissen,
dass die auch für meinen Geschmack etwas viel senden.
Das siehst du ja schon beim Setup, wenn das Ding erst einmal
dich die meisten Sachen schon gar nicht mehr ausschalten lässt,
sondern nur noch auf Basic switchbar ist.
Du kannst ja, du musst ja am Anfang, wenn du Windows 11 installierst,
irgendwie, was weiß ich, zwölf verschiedene Fragen beantworten
und keines davon kannst du richtig ausschalten.
Moment, mein RGB, ja, jetzt RGB an der Tastatur tut wieder richtig.
Dann ist jetzt alles gut.
Ich muss die Klimaanlage anmachen, hier ist 30 Grad.
Nein, das kann nicht sein.
Also, laut meiner geflashten Uhr, habe ich euch ja gezeigt, das Teil,
das ist das China-Chinesen-Ur-Ding mit Custom-Firmware,
die zeigt an, angeblich wäre hier 30 Grad.
Das glaube ich aber nicht.
30 Grad ist doch etwas viel.
So viel hatten wir die letzten Tage über nicht draußen.
Wie soll es denn 30 Grad hier drinnen warm werden?
Ich tippe mal eher so auf, lasst mal kurz in mein Home Assistant reingucken.
24, ja, ja.
24 haben wir.
Ja.
24 ist mir auch zu warm.
Dementsprechend werde ich mal meine Klimaanlage anmachen.
Welches OS soll ich nutzen?
Das OS, wo es die Software drauf gibt, die du brauchst.
Nicht, was nicht viel Möglichkeiten, oder?
Ansonsten Arch Linux, by the way.
Was sonst?
Arch Enjoyers.
Mal kurz die VM an.
Eine Runde Arch Linux Package Updates.
Die Tümpelmusik ist ein bisschen laut.
Ja, besser.
DOS?
Nee, DOS ist...
DOS ist das Einfachste.
DOS-Box funktioniert wunderbar.
Als wenn du wirklich ein DOS brauchst.
Weil, für was?
Ja.
Dann ist das unter Linux tatsächlich kein Ding.
So, Package Updates.
Aber ich glaube, du willst mich jibaden.
Wer braucht denn DOS heutzutage tagtäglich?
Für was denn?
Hier.
Keine User-Repo-Updates.
Was ist da los?
Ja, dann Package Updates schon alle durch.
Okay.
Ja, aber schneller, als ich gedacht habe.
Egal.
Reboot.
Ja.
Ja, nur Steuercomputer von der Bahn.
Oder irgendwelche Computer bei der Bahn.
Windows 3.11.
So, schauen wir mal.
Dann zeige ich euch, was wir jetzt machen.
Der Stream kann nervig werden oder super schnell gehen.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Aber allzu schnell geht er nicht, weil ich habe zwei Themen heute für den Stream.
Das zweite ist fast noch nicer wie das erste.
Aber das steht nicht im Titel.
Das wird erst later revealed.
Ich sage gleich was dazu.
Aber was wir heute ausprobieren, ist folgendes.
Ich habe mir auf Amazon einen Sonoff Zigbee Dongle E gekauft.
Das ist der allerneueste Zigbee Dongle von...
Zigbee Dongle ist ein dummes Wort.
Der allerneueste Zigbee Stick von...
Das ist übrigens nicht der E, glaube ich.
Der E.
Ich bin nicht in der Lage jetzt richtig zu tippen.
Das ist der richtige hier.
Ja.
Das ist der neueste Zigbee Stick von Sonoff.
Und das ist der erste mit diesem E-Blub-Whatever-Chip-Satz.
Der Vorteil davon ist, dass man mit nur einem Stick Zigbee machen kann, Thread machen kann
und dementsprechend auch Matt-Stick machen kann.
Also man kann quasi zwei Funk-Protokolle mit dem gleichen Stick laufen lassen.
Der neue kostet weniger als der alte.
Naja gut.
Also das Ding scheint auch gerade irgendwie nicht richtig lieferbar zu sein.
Der alte ist nicht schlecht.
Also wenn man einfach was haben will, nur für Zigbee was funktioniert, dann ist der alte tatsächlich besser.
Hast du gesehen, der Fabian streamt Gears 5?
Ne, hab ich nicht gesehen.
Ernsthaft?
Der heißt...
Er heißt ja nicht mal iFreesy.
Ich hab vergessen.
iFreesy Twitch.
Wie heißt er denn jetzt?
So?
Ja.
Zeig mal.
Der Frasier.
Wo ist er?
Der Frasier streamt Gears.
Tatsächlich.
Guck mal da.
Matcher Audience.
Zeit 5 Stunden.
Der Grind is real.
Ja, der Fabian mochte Gears of War schon immer.
Ich bin da nie so richtig reingekommen, aber der fand das schon immer megageil.
MW3.
Ja, wäre geil, wenn es einfach mal ein richtig nices Game geben würde wieder.
Auf das ich auch Bock hätte.
In dieser Richtung.
Ja, Gears, Cod ist egal.
Was wir zusammen spielen können.
MW3 finde ich hat so richtig reingesackt.
Da hab ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Ich glaube, das größte Problem ist...
Nicht so sehr für mich die Abnutzungserscheinung.
Nicht so sehr für mich die Abnutzungserscheinung von Call of Duty.
Was auch da ist, aber ich hab die letzten Jahre über kaum gespielt.
Das ist es nicht.
Ich glaube, der große Unterschied ist, dass die Leute, die heute Call of Duty herstellen,
das nicht mehr aus Leidenschaft machen.
Und ich finde, das merkt man.
Das ist einfach nur noch ein Massenprodukt.
Das war es in gewisser Zeit schon sehr lange.
Aber gerade zu Zeiten von Cod 4, 5, Black Ops 1 und noch ein, zwei Sachen, die danach kamen,
war das...
Echt.
Zumindest vom Gefühl her von Leuten gemacht, die da richtig Bock dran hatten.
Meinst du, was kann man den Dingern...
Kann ich da draufklicken?
Nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie bei einem Riesendildo oder so rauskomme.
Mal gucken, was da für ein Link ist.
Okay, kann man da klicken.
Wir sind heute Noobs.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir Noobs sind.
Es gibt heute halt einfach deutlich weniger.
Damals konnte die Leute ja schon beeindruckt werden.
Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass die einfach nur unfähig sind.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass die einfach nur unfähig sind.
Wobei, heute kannst du ja auch gar nicht mehr gescheit Soundcues in dem Game danach gehen.
Fußschritte von rechts, Gegner kommt von links und sowas.
Das haben sie so heftig verkackt.
Das ist aber Absicht.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass die einfach nur unfähig sind.
Also, man...
Auch ältere Leute kriegen das hin, wenn sie Bock haben und das Game hart reinkreien.
Wo ich tatsächlich beeindruckt bin, wie gut heute...
Ich gucke mir manchmal den einen oder anderen Warzone-Stream noch an.
Wie gut heute Leute...
Wie gut heute Leute abgehen auf der Konsole.
Natürlich gibt es dann die Hater, die sagen, ach, das ist alles Auto-Aim.
Aber da sieht man so viele Sachen, die mit Auto-Aim nichts zu tun haben.
Ja?
Dass da schon...
Allein das Movement, dass keiner mehr hängen bleibt.
Dass in die richtige Richtung geslidet wird.
Obwohl es halt noch nicht klar ist, wo der Gegner ist.
Dass irgendwelche Pre-Granaten hingeschmissen werden.
Das ist teilweise super High-IQ-Gameplay in den Warzone-Streams.
Was ich mir da angucke.
Und, na gut, der Controller-Auto-Aim kommt vielleicht noch ein bisschen dazu.
Aber das...
Das insgesamte Spielverständnis und Skill-Level bei den Streamern, die ich mir da teilweise Warzone angucke,
ist auch auf der Konsole enorm hoch.
Ja?
Kann man nicht anders sagen.
Battlefield läuft bei mir.
Also, ohne Mist, du kannst mich irgendwie an jedes Battlefield setzen.
Und nach...
Nachdem ich mich da mal eine Woche eingespielt habe oder ein paar Tage eingespielt habe,
wird gebasht.
Ja.
Teilzeit-Montag-Stream.
Das merke ich auch jedes Mal, wenn ich mal irgendwann wieder in 2042 reingucke, ja?
Die ersten 1, 2, 3 Runden sind kacke, danach geht's ab.
Ja.
Ich hab den Captain Poggers dabei manchmal.
Den hab ich schon lange nicht mehr gesehen, wo ist der eigentlich?
WC2 war beste.
Ich glaube, WC2 würde heute keinen mehr hinter dem Montag vorloggen.
Einer.
Ais, Joey, danke schön für den Sub.
Exposing-YouTube-Video rendert schon.
Oh, da muss ich aber schnell noch mal auf AnniTheDuck reagieren.
Dass du auch Content hast.
Ich hab überhaupt keine Ahnung davon.
Ich hab mir weder die ganzen Reactions angeguckt, noch das Apology-Video, noch weiß ich überhaupt, um was es geht.
Und es ist mir scheißegal, ich will's gar nicht wissen.
Nee, nee, nee, ich guck mir das garantiert nicht an.
Nie.
Die ganzen...
Ich ignoriere die ganzen Beefs.
Ich ignoriere die nicht, weil ich mir denke, oh, fuck, Alter, willst du dich geben?
Ja, nee.
Das will...
Es interessiert mich legit alles nicht.
Wie gesagt, der einzige Beef, den ich so ein bisschen...
Mitverfolgt hab, weil ich's übelst lustig fand, war KuchenTV oder Shurioka vs. KuchenTV.
Wo dann jeder mit den Anwälten irgendwie rumgeschrieben hat.
Das fand ich ganz unterhaltsam, ja.
Das soll ich mir angucken.
Okay, was war die Frage dazu nochmal?
Kann man den Dingern 230 Volt anvertrauen?
Was hältst du davon, sowas wie Shelleys selbst zu bauen?
Ich würde Shelleys nicht selbst bauen, weil ich mir einfach einen fertigen Shelley kaufen kann.
Es gibt ja noch ein paar andere.
Es gibt mittlerweile von Sonoff Dinger, die man unter Putz einbaut.
Es gibt noch diese Q-Bit Dinger oder Q-Bit Dinger, kleine.
Also Sonoff Shelley ist nicht mehr das Einzige in der Richtung.
Da hab ich letztens noch irgendeine andere Alternative gesehen.
Hab ich aber schon wieder voll verdrängt, was das war.
Ansonsten, ich würde keinen Shelley selbst bauen.
So ein kleines, kompaktes, ja, irgendwo auch battle-testedes Produkt, weil es so viele verwenden, schüttelst du dich einfach mal so aus dem Ärmel.
Okay.
Ich würde den Dingern 230 Volt rumhantieren, selbst gebaut, würde ich eh aus Prinzip nicht, sondern auf die Frage, ob man diesen Dinger 230 Volt anvertrauen, was, 220 Volt zu 5 Volt Mininetzteil.
Ah, ich denke schon, dass man das machen kann.
Zumindest einmal.
Was sagen denn die Bewertungen?
Leider unbrauchbar.
Also nachdem ich nicht mit 230 Volt rumhantieren und es auch keinem empfehlen würde, da irgendwas zu basteln, wenn man nicht weiß, was ich mache.
Ich denke schon, dass sie das prinzipiell aushalten.
Von den Specs her, dass man den halbwegs trauen kann, was da draufsteht.
Aber ich würde es trotzdem nicht machen.
Damals auf die Panther Nuke, ich habe, habe ich, ich habe, ich habe was dazu gesagt.
Irgendwann mal, ich habe, glaube ich, nie drauf reaktet.
Ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher, war die Panther Nuke das gefakte, wo das Solution danach irgendwie die richtige hoch, ich kriege es gar nicht mehr, ich kriege es gar nicht mehr auf die Reihe.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Deswegen, da würde ich gar nicht irgendwie rumspielen mit.
So, zumindest, zumindest, was wir heute machen, ist folgendes.
Ich habe mir so einen USB-Stick hier bestellt, also das ist der, der neueste Sonoff USB, Zigbee, Zigbee USB-Stick.
Und was man dort machen kann, ist, Tesco hatte noch eine Panther, ich, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Ich, ich habe echt keine Ahnung mehr, kann mich da nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Ich glaube, der Frasier und ich, ich, ich, wir sind über Double Nuke nie rausgekommen.
Kann mich nicht dran erinnern.
Ich glaube, ich habe legit nie ein Nuke-Gameplay von mir hochgeladen.
Ich habe das Ding auch auf meinem Main-Account bis heute absichtlich nicht unlockt, weil ich Nuke-Gameplays schon immer übelst dumm fand.
Weil die Nuke-Gameplays, gerade am Anfang und, und später auch zum größten Teil, die waren super billig.
Das war immer das gleiche.
Übelste Kack-Noobs, Harrier, Chopper-Gunner oder, oder, ähm, AC-130.
Und dann...
Nuke, bam, du-du-du-du-du.
Ja.
Und dann gab's...
Unregelmäßig.
Ja, damals haben wir uns doch drüber aufgeregt, wenn Leute YouTube-Partner geworden sind.
Stimmt.
Ich habe ja, ich habe ja sogar ein Video gemacht, in dem ich gesagt habe, ich werde nie Partner werden.
So kann man sich täuschen.
Ja, da waren schon mal coole Sachen dabei.
Das setzt aber voraus, dass man Bock auf das...
...Game hat.
Ja, war's auch nicht, ich weiß.
Ich, ich hab einfach aktuell keinen Bock drauf.
Also, wo ich mich richtig drüber freuen würde, ist, wenn's ein neues Battlefield gibt, was ja angeblich schon in Entwicklung ist.
Und der EA-Chef das auch übelst feiert, aber ich weiß, seriously, was soll er denn sonst sagen?
Vielleicht hat er intern gesagt, Alter, ihr Kack-Noobs, was habt ihr da wieder von Schrott programmiert?
Aber...
Aber, nach außen wird natürlich gesagt, yeah, größtes Battlefield-Team, was je an einem Battlefield gearbeitet hat.
Ein super krasses Game.
Was das größte Battlefield-Team aller Zeiten, was an Battlefield-Arbeit gemacht hat, sieht man in Battlefield 2042.
Irgendein Game, was den wenigsten Map-Pool hatte, wenigsten Content, so viel dummes Zeug drinne zu release.
Wie noch keins davor, Hazard Zone, was übelst reingeschissen hat.
Und eine Fahrzeugphysik, die überhaupt nicht zu gebrauchen war, nur weil sie dann irgendwie ein Need for Speed-Leute mit am Start hatten.
Also...
...
Dann ...
Dann lieber kleineres Battlefield-Team, das weiß, was es macht.
Aber das gibt's ja nicht mehr, weil die sind ja alle weg.
Ist schon doof, ne?
Da hätte ich aber echt Bock drauf.
Ich hab aber schon...
...
Naja, vielleicht die Hoffnung nicht ganz aufgegeben.
Aber meine Erwartungshaltung ist sehr gering.
Ob da nochmal was richtig Gutes kommt.
Der Frasier erinnert sich noch einer an...
...unser Video, wo wir das RC XD, ne wie hieß das Ding, RC XD, dieses Auto aus der Black Ops Collector's Edition ausgepackt haben.
Ja.
Unboxing.
Find das überhaupt nicht mehr.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja.
Da wo der Fabian noch aussah wie 17, obwohl wir damals auch schon irgendwie 24 waren.
Bist du eigentlich mit der GoPro zufrieden?
Nutzt du mich?
Ja, mach.
Ich hatte die heute kurz wieder dran.
Was ich bei der GoPro sehr nice finde ist, dass das Autorz übelst im Rumgewackel, also ich nehm aber halt auch mit 60 FPS auf, recht weich aussieht.
Tim, hast du dir in die Liste gemacht, was du jetzt in den Chat alles rein spammen willst?
Da geht's ja hier Schlag auf Schlag, Alter.
Netzwerklatenz.
Da hab ich mal ein Video gemacht vor 5 Jahren drüber.
Du kannst höchstwahrscheinlich nichts machen.
Weil das nicht an dir liegt.
Außerdem sind 10 bis 100, ja.
Das ist von ziemlich gut zu Kacke.
Früher war 100 Millisekunden Ping, hat man sich drüber gefreut.
Zu Zeiten von Oldschool DSL mit...
Wie hieß dieser Shit nochmal, was die da hatten?
Diese Fehlerkorrektur, wo ich nie verstanden hab, wozu es die gab, war DSL...
Interleaving oder sowas?
Kann das sein?
DSL Interleaving?
Der Fastpass ist das Abschalten von Interleaving.
So hieß das, glaub ich, ja.
Naja.
Oh, genug altes Zeug.
Also, was ich probieren will, ist folgendes.
Ich hab mir diesen Stick...
Oh, ich muss nochmal anzufangen.
Ich hab mir diesen Stick bestellt, weil das übrigens nicht die erste Variante ist.
Ich hab drei Sticks von denen.
Einen alten Stick und zwei von diesen E-Sticks.
Aber der eine E-Stick, der ist als Extender, ist der bei mir im Stall.
So, also, ich hab mir diesen ZigBee-Stick gekauft.
Also, er hat den allerneuesten Chip, die es so für ZigBees gibt.
Also, es ist dementsprechend auch der neueste Stick von Sonoff, wobei Sonoff nicht der Chip-Hersteller ist.
Zumindest, was man damit machen kann, ist, man kann das wohl mit einer...
Es ist keine richtige Custom-Firmware, weil es ist nicht, was irgendein Dude auf GitHub, glaub ich, programmiert hat,
sondern es ist, glaub ich, eine offizielle Firmware vom Hersteller.
Man kann das Ding flashen, und zwar gibt es die Möglichkeit...
Ich versuch das mal zusammenzufassen.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich auf Reddit gelesen hab, ja?
Es gibt drei verschiedene Firmware-Pakete für diesen Stick.
Die erste Firmware ist die, mit der er auch ausgeliefert wird.
Da ist es ein stinknormaler ZigBee...
Wie heißt das?
ZigBee-Gateway-Stick.
Oder ZigBee-Controller-Stick, oder sowas.
All das, was man sich normalerweise in sein Smart-Home-Gerät steckt, um dort alle ZigBee-Geräte mit zu pairn.
Das ist die Default-Firmware.
Dann gibt es eine Router-Firmware.
Das ist, wenn man sein ZigBee-Netzwerk extenden will.
ZigBee ist ja ein Mesh-Netzwerk.
Das heißt, von der Theorie her, sowas wie Z-Wave beispielsweise auch, und Thread, das ist, glaub ich, ähnlich.
Jeder ZigBee-Node, der permanent am Strom hängt,
der dient quasi als Relay, beziehungsweise als Router für andere Geräte.
Das heißt, du kannst quasi einen ZigBee-Controller an dein Rechner anschließen,
und dann verteilst du im Haus ZigBee-Steckdosen oder eben solche Sticks
oder irgendwelche anderen ZigBee-Geräte, die permanent am Strom angeschlossen sind.
Also USB geht auch.
Und die vernetzen sich dann untereinander.
Und dann kannst du quasi dein Netz relativ lückenlos auch über größere Quadratmeter, Grundstück und alles aufspannen.
Also das ist die zweite Variante.
Du kannst das Ding als ZigBee-Router flashen.
Dass das eben ZigBee-Signale weiterleitet, Teil vom Mesh-Netzwerk wird.
Und die dritte Firmware ist eine reine Low-Level-Funk-Firmware.
Da wird im Prinzip dieser Stick nicht mehr als ZigBee-Stick verwendet,
sondern nur noch als Low-Level-Radio-Stick.
Damit man dann ZigBee machen kann oder Thread und Meta über Thread,
braucht man Zusatzsoftware, die nicht auf dem Stick mit drauf ist,
sondern als zusätzliche Software auf der Linux-Kiste läuft, wo man eben seine Heimautomatisierung drauf hat.
Und das wollte ich mal ausprobieren.
Wir werden das auf zwei Varianten ausprobieren.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, ich schalte mal kurz hier meine Home Assistant-Kiste an.
Und mache da mal ein Update, weil die ist schon ein paar Tage älter.
Machen wir mal Rebooten.
Trinkst du Alkohol oder rauchst du?
Ne, also ich rauche nichts, egal was.
Und ich trinke auch nichts.
Die einzigen Sachen, wo ich mal ab und an, und das auch nicht jedes Jahr, was trinke,
ist vielleicht dann Weihnachten und zu Silvester irgendwas.
Und selbst da merke ich, ich halte ja auch gar nichts aus.
Ich trinke irgendwie so ein Mini-Sekt-Glas und merke schon was.
Bin das nicht gewohnt.
Das ist tatsächlich, also aus den Gesichtspunkten lebe ich relativ gesund.
Ich lebe aber insgesamt glaube ich trotzdem nicht allzu gesund.
Ich fresse viel zu viel ungesundes Zeug.
Und ich sitze den ganzen Tag.
Dafür, dafür bin ich mittlerweile nicht mehr zu dick.
Und ich bin mittlerweile tatsächlich, sowohl was Blutdruck angeht, als auch konditionsmäßig, bin ich echt ganz gut dabei für mein Alter.
Bin heute, bin ich, haltet euch fest.
Heute Morgen bin ich nicht da.
Wo ist mein, wo ist mein Handy?
Ich sage es euch genau.
Ich brauche jetzt nicht die Sparkassen-App.
Was der Doktor Kabum macht.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich, ich weiß nur das letzte von ihm.
Er arbeitet bei einem größeren deutschen Autohersteller.
Wie es aktuell ist, keine Ahnung.
Also heute, heute, also heute Morgen bin ich fünf Kilometer durch hier durchs Ort gelaufen zum Einkaufen.
Das habe ich, das track ich.
Ja, das, da gibt es so eine Sportaktivität, kannst du sagen, Walking.
Fünf, fünf Kilometer.
4,91.
Danach bin ich gerannt.
Gerannt 38 Minuten.
5,84 Kilometer.
Durchschnitts-Pace 6 Minuten 32.
Das waren jeweils zehn Minuten einlaufen, zehn Minuten auslaufen und ja, 17 Minuten at 5,55 Pace rennen.
Ne, 17 Minuten, 17 Minuten.
So, und danach war ich noch eine Stunde zehn, 25 Kilometer Fahrrad fahren.
Also, wenn das nicht reicht, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Du fährst Inlineskates, nice.
Was fährst du für Inlineskates?
Ich würde nämlich auch gerne wieder Inlineskates fahren.
Ich bin früher sehr viel Inlineskates gefahren.
Ich habe da überhaupt keinen Durchblick mehr, was es gab.
Früher hatte ich, früher hatte ich vieler, vieler Inlineskates.
K2 Boa, okay.
K2 gibt es auch schon ewig, ne.
Ja.
Ja, also das habe ich heute gemacht.
Das sollte reichen.
Und wenn ich meinen Kalender angucke, dann habe ich außer gestern.
Gestern ist tatsächlich der Tag gewesen, an dem ich mal zur Abwechslung gar nichts gemacht habe.
Weder gelaufen, noch gerannt, noch Fahrrad gefahren.
Aber davor jeder Tag mindestens eine Fahrradfahren-Rennen-Activity.
Plus, plus ein bisschen rumlaufen.
Fünf, sechs Kilometer.
Ja.
Jeden Tag.
Und dann hier mal Dienstag wieder einmal nichts.
Also es sind immer so fünf, sechs Tage, dann mal einen Tag Pause.
Ja.
Also wie gesagt, mittlerweile, ich habe, ich messe ja regelmäßig morgens, mittags, ich habe so ein Blutdruck-Messgerät da liegen.
Ich habe echt, ich habe in meinem Leben noch nicht so guten Blutdruck gehabt.
Ja.
Ich habe irgendwas, keine Ahnung, was ist das?
Ich habe den, ich habe diese Auswertungs-App nicht, weil die sagt so irgendwas 110, keine Ahnung, 110, 70 oder irgendwie sowas.
Manchmal auch nur ein bisschen weniger.
Das ist, ich habe, wie gesagt, noch nie so guten Blutdruck.
Springt, springt, bringt Spazier-, ja natürlich bringt das was, ja.
Klar kenne ich Matrix, das ist eines meiner favorite Filme ever.
Und sonst war der Blutdruck wie hoch?
Ich habe schon lange keinen zu hohen Blutdruck mehr.
Ich, ich hatte vor einigen Jahren etwas zu hohen Blutdruck, so 145, 100 oder was, 145, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Irgendwie, der war ein bisschen zu hoch.
Und damals habe ich so die, die Minimaldosis von meinem Doktor verschrieben gekriegt an Blutdruck-Tabletten.
Aber seit ich angefangen habe, mich mehr zu bewegen, ist mein Blutdruck wirklich viel, viel besser geworden.
Ja, und jetzt ist er echt so gut wie noch nie zuvor.
Ich glaube, und das ist jetzt echt der Witz, ich, ich muss, ich bin, ich bin, ihr dürft nicht vergessen, ich bin fast 40, ja.
Ich werde in ein paar Monaten 40.
Und ich glaube, ich war in meinem Leben noch nie so fit wie jetzt.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich erstmal 40 werden musste dafür.
Und ich war früher relativ fit, ja.
Früher konnte ich kilometerweit schwimmen.
Und sowas schwimmen ist jetzt nicht mehr so meins gerade, aber dafür eher Rennen und Fahrrad fahren.
Ich konnte kilometerweit schwimmen und war super aktiv und alles.
Aber so richtig strukturiert, so mit, jeden Tag mit nach einem Plan was machen, auch wenn es ein automatisch erstellter Plan ist von der Garmin-App, habe ich, das habe ich noch nie gemacht, ja.
Und seitdem ich das mache, bin ich insgesamt auch fit.
Bin ich insgesamt auch viel fitter.
Und eins habe ich gemerkt, ich habe viel mehr Hunger.
Ich habe vorher schon übelst viel gefressen, aber das Problem war, früher habe ich übelst viel gefressen, zum größten Teil kompletten Schrott gefressen und mich nicht bewegt.
Ich meine, seriously, wie sieht, wie sieht mein Tagesablauf aus?
Wir kommen gleich zum ZigBee-Stick, Leute, ja.
Wie sah früher, wie sah früher mein Tagesablauf aus?
Ernsthaft.
Ich meine, Münze, danke.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Wie sah früher mein Tagesablauf aus?
Ihr wisst, ich arbeite in Frankfurt mittlerweile bei einer Versicherung in der IT.
Das heißt, meiste, meisten Tage der Woche Homeoffice.
Das heißt, da fällt sogar irgendwie mal Bahn hin und zurück zum Bahnhof laufen weg.
Ich bin, ich stehe morgens auf oder sagen wir mal, bevor ich, bevor ich Sportsachen gemacht habe, ja.
Ich stehe auf um 7.30 Uhr oder so.
Setze mich an den Rechner.
Dann futter ich vielleicht mal kurz was dazwischen.
Ja, gehe ich runter in die Küche, futter mal was dazwischen.
Ich sitze dann quasi von 7.30 Uhr bis, ja, 15, 15.30 Uhr, 16 Uhr, je nachdem, wie viel los.
Mach auch nur 14 Uhr.
Also ich sitze da irgendwie 7, 8, 9, je nachdem, je nachdem, was los ist.
Stunden am Stück am Rechner.
So.
Und dann war ich fertig.
Und was habe ich dann gemacht?
Dann bin ich einfach weiter am Rechner sitzen geblieben.
Bin ich einfach hocken geblieben.
Habe dann entweder was für YouTube gemacht, gestreamsort, irgendwas für mich programmiert, Sachen gespielt, MMOs gecrindet, was auch immer.
Ja, du bist schon viel zu lange dabei.
Und dann bin ich um 22 Uhr oder so petten gegangen.
Und das habe ich jeden Tag so gemacht.
Und am Wochenende, sagen wir mal Samstag, Sonntag und Montag, ich arbeite ja schon sehr lange Teilzeit.
Da war es das Gleiche.
Da habe ich auch von morgens bis abends am Rechner gesessen, so.
Und das habe ich jahrelang gemacht.
Jahrzehnte kann man eigentlich sagen.
Ja, Jahrzehnte ist übertrieben.
Ein Jahrzehnt oder so habe ich das gemacht.
Dann habe ich irgendwann festgestellt, dass man immer mehr Probleme kriegt.
Dass einem der Kopf weh tut, man Rückenprobleme kriegt, Kreislaufprobleme kriegt, ja.
Und irgendwann...
Ich glaube, der ausschlaggebende Punkt bei mir ist gewesen, wo ich angefangen habe, darüber nachzudenken, mich vielleicht mal etwas mehr zu bewegen, ist,
als ich von heute auf morgen doppelte Herzschläge hatte.
Hattet ihr sowas schon mal?
Da kriegt das echt ein bisschen mit der Angst zu tun, wenn ihr das noch nicht hattet.
Doppelte Herzschläge.
Das fühlt sich ungefähr ein bisschen so an.
Ja.
Ja, und ich weiß, wir haben total viele hier, Leute.
Ich habe schon öfters mal gefragt, wer war früher so richtig nerviges Call-of-Duty-Flamer-Kind?
Hebt mal eure Hand, Leute.
Wer war früher am Start und sagt heute von sich selbst, er war so richtig nerviges Call-of-Duty-Flamer-Kind?
Ich sage das über mich selbst, ja.
Ich war zwar kein Call-of-Duty-Flamer-Kind mehr, dafür andere Games früher.
Ja, wir haben total viele.
Ja.
Immer noch. Heute noch.
Golden Kappa Sport.
Ja, zumindest...
Ich weiß, ich bin ein bisschen side-getrackt, jetzt gerade so minimal vom ZigBee-Stick.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, es geht eh schnell.
Danach habe ich ja noch was Spezielles für euch.
So, zumindest das erste, wo mir das aufgefallen ist, wo sich vielleicht mal ein bisschen mehr zu bewegen ist.
Als ich von heute auf morgen angefangen habe, so doppelte Herzschläge zu haben.
Mein Doktor hat dann damals gesagt, das ist eigentlich nichts Schlimmes.
Da passiert nichts davon, Alter.
Da stirbt man nicht von und das muss man auch gar nicht groß behandeln.
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Fühlt sich nur ein bisschen komisch an.
Aber das hat sich echt sehr merkwürdig angefühlt.
Das könnt ihr euch ungefähr so vorstellen wie...
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr lauft, ihr geht spazieren und neben euch ist ein Gassi-Gänger.
Die Situation kennt wahrscheinlich jeder.
Oder ihr geht an einem...
Ich weiß, ich habe noch ein besseres Beispiel.
Ihr geht an einer Straße lang auf dem Gehweg und auf einmal bellt euch ein Hund an.
Von hinter einem Hoftor, wo ihr nicht durchgucken konntet, wo ihr nicht wusstet, dass er da ist.
In dem Moment kriegt ja jeder so einen kleinen Adrenalinstoß.
So, wow, was ist das?
Und ungefähr, nicht ganz so krass, aber ungefähr so fühlen sich doppelte Herzschläge an.
Nach dem ersten Herzschlag.
Du hast...
Dein Herz schlägt nochmal und beim zweiten Herzschlag hast du irgendwie so einen Mini-Adrenalinstoß noch dabei.
Fühlt sich super weird an.
Und da habe ich mir jetzt angefangen Gedanken drüber zu machen.
Okay, Max, weißt du was?
Es ist vielleicht doch nicht so gut für den Rest deines Lebens, also quasi so dann die nächsten 70 Jahre oder so,
auch 16 Stunden vorm Rechner zu sitzen.
Das ist vielleicht nice, ja.
Aber es ist nicht so nice.
Wenn man dauerhaft Kopfweh, Kreislaufprobleme, einem der Arsch wehtut, whatever.
Das ist vielleicht doch nicht so nice.
Deswegen sollte man vielleicht so mal ein bisschen zwischendurch sich ein bisschen bewegen.
Da habe ich angefangen, einfach ein bisschen hier wie auch durch die Pampa zu laufen.
Ich habe mir vorgenommen, jeden Tag eine Stunde ein bisschen durch die Pampa laufen, hier so durch den Wald.
Es gibt ja relativ...
In Hessen gibt es ja...
Hessen ist das waldreichste Bundesland.
Da gibt es relativ viel Wald.
Da bin ich ein bisschen durch den Wald gelaufen.
So, und seitdem ich angefangen habe, das zu machen, ging es eigentlich immer besser.
Und das habe ich ausgeweitet, bis ich irgendwann jeden Tag eigentlich mindestens eineinhalb Stunden gelaufen bin.
Mit laufen meine ich wirklich laufen.
Nicht rennen, joggen, sondern wirklich laufen.
So, keine Ahnung, 11 Minuten 30 pro Kilometer oder sowas.
Also relativ, so halbwegs zügig normales Gehen, ja.
Laufen.
Und das...
Irgendwann bin ich dann so hängengeblieben so zwischen...
Dass ich zwischen eineinhalb und zwei Stunden jeden Tag, nachdem ich fertig war mit Homeoffice oder von Frankfurt hergekommen bin, durch den Wald gelaufen bin.
Und seitdem ging das alles weg, was ich hatte, ja.
Kreislaufgeschichten, Rückenprobleme, alles.
Ging alles wirklich...
Das hat natürlich ein bisschen gedauert, aber ging alles weg.
So.
Und irgendwann habe ich das...
Ich habe das dann eine Weile gemacht.
Und irgendwann habe ich mir dann gedacht, ey Max.
Du gehst jetzt jeden Tag ja relativ zügig.
Hier so eineinhalb Stunden da durch den Wald laufen.
Willst du nicht mal ausprobieren, wie lange du es aushältst, wenn du versuchst ein Stück zu rennen.
So.
Und dann habe ich mir so eine Garmin Uhr gekauft.
So ne, ich habe eine...
Garmin 4Runner245S.
Ich glaube so ein Ding.
Und es kostet definitiv nicht nur 30 Euro, auch wenn das Garmin anzeigt.
Ja, so ein Teil hier.
Und dann habe ich mir das so gekauft.
Was ist das Problem, Garmin?
Ah, irgendwie...
Ich glaube...
Am ehesten sowas.
So ein Teil gekauft.
Und...
Dann bin ich tatsächlich zum ersten Mal...
Ach ja, natürlich, das sollte ich vielleicht auch noch sagen.
Ich habe kontinuierlich immer weiter zugenommen.
Also ich bin immer fetter geworden.
Auch die ganze Zeit.
Wo ich dann immer mehr vom Rechner...
Wie gesagt, ich habe ja ein Jahrzehnt quasi 24-7 vom Rechner verbracht.
Ich bin auch immer fetter geworden.
Und irgendwann hatte ich 108,5.
Und ich bin 1,74 groß.
Also das war... Moment.
WMI-Rechner.
Die werden sagen, das ist Massive-Pepo-Fett.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ich stelle einfach mal 35 ein.
Irgendwas...
Alter! Boah, das laggt!
Wie schafft man das bitteschön?
Einen BMI-Rechner zum laggen zu bringen.
Aber 109, komm.
Ich bin viel zu fett, steht da.
Ihr BMI weist auf Übergewicht hin.
Ich habe ein BMI von 36.
Das ist Massive-Fett.
Hier, die anderen Tabs sind noch da.
Macht ihr keine Gedanken.
Also das ist ordentlich fett.
Und das ging natürlich dann auch ein bisschen runter.
Ich bin glaube ich der einzige in Deutschland,
der während Corona abgenommen hat, anstatt zu.
Zumindest, wenn man es in Erzählungen so glaubt.
Also ich habe tatsächlich
während der Corona-Zeit, wo sehr viel Homeoffice angesagt war,
deutlich mehr abgenommen als davor,
weil ich da das ganze Pendeln nicht mehr hatte
und richtig Bock hatte nach dem Homeoffice
in den Wald zu gehen. Zumindest
irgendwann habe ich mir dann gedacht, weißt du was?
Max, probier doch mal aus.
Das war so der Anstoß dessen. Ich mache ein bisschen mehr Sport.
Probier doch mal aus.
Jetzt nachdem du jetzt eine ganze Weile,
mindestens jeden Tag eineinhalb Stunden
normal durch den Wald gelaufen bist, relativ zügig,
wie lange hältst du das ein?
Wie lange schaffst du es eigentlich,
wenn du rennst?
Ja, dann habe ich im Internet mal geschaut,
also habe ich mir diese Uhr hier gekauft
und dann habe ich im Internet mal geschaut,
was ist denn so eine gute Geschwindigkeit
um einzusteigen und da habe ich im Internet
gefunden, ja, Einsteiger sollten mal
probieren, ob sie es schaffen, so
8 Minuten 30 pro Kilometer
und dann habe ich das probiert.
Ich habe es nicht wirklich lange
den kompletten Weg durchgehalten.
Ich glaube, ich habe es bei meinem ersten Joggingversuch
habe ich das geschafft,
ich glaube, dreieinhalb Kilometer
hier so ein paar Mal im Kreis
am Main, dreieinhalb Kilometer
so ungefähr
ich glaube, ich glaube so
8,45 pro Kilometer
oder sowas, also
8 Minuten 45 Sekunden
pro Kilometer, das ist super langsam,
ja, wenn man sich das mit
mit jetzt vergleicht
und zumindest
anstelle normalerweise
normalerweise
bei sowas hätte ich mir jetzt gedacht, boah ey
das ist ja anstrengend und
kein Bock, aber
war witzigerweise komplett anders
ich habe mir gedacht, ey das lief ja
eigentlich ganz gut
dazu kam, dass ich mir diese
Uhr angefangen habe, meine normalen Runden
und so alles zu tracken und so
so ein Tracking ist sehr motivierend
in der App, weil man sieht grüne Pfeile
nach oben, grüne Pfeile nach oben
sind nicht nur auf YouTube motivierend, sondern auch
wenn es um irgendwelche Fitnessgeschichten
geht, Incident Detected
das habe ich noch nicht
ja, und seitdem
bin ich tatsächlich regelmäßig
rennen gegangen und mittlerweile
ist das bei mir so geplant
ah ja, dann habe ich irgendwann noch angefangen
ähm
dann habe ich angefangen, habe ich mir ein Fahrrad gekauft
habe ich natürlich gleich einen Unfall gebaut
habe ich euch ja schon erzählt
mache ich das regelmäßig
sogar so regelmäßig
dass ich so eine Art Plan habe
was ich wie mache, das ist zwar ein
von der App generierter Plan, wann ich wie
was machen muss, ich kann euch auch gleich sagen
was ich machen muss, und zwar
heute habe ich das schon durch
gucken wir mal, was
Workouts als nächstes
ansteht
Training, Workouts, Daily
Suggestions, heute
completed, tomorrow base
heißt
42 Minuten
7 Minuten 5
das ist
nicht schnell, aber base
so
Mittwoch
oh shit
Mittwoch wird anstrengend
mal
steckt das
nicht, ah jetzt ist das Licht ausgegangen von der Uhr
7 mal
eine Minute
ja das wird, also Mittwoch wird anstrengend
und davor jeweils eine Viertelstunde
einlaufen und Viertelstunde auslaufen
dazwischen dann irgendwie 3 Minuten langsam laufen
Pause, Mittwoch wird anstrengend
wobei Mittwoch kann ich nicht
Mittwoch muss ich nach Frankfurt fahren
gut, scheiß drauf
sowas generiert einem das
das ist eigentlich ganz nice
und daran halte ich mich
und jetzt gehe ich eigentlich jeden Tag
mindestens eine Sache machen, wenn nicht zwei
Sachen, wie gesagt, heute war ich normal
meine Runde laufen, danach eine Runde rennen
und jetzt nochmal 1 Stunde 10 Fahrrad fahren
so, lange Rede kurzer Sinn
ich war noch nie so fit wie jetzt
so, jetzt
wie auch immer ich da jetzt drauf gekommen bin
das ist echt so, ja
das ist mega motivierend
ist 2100
brutto für Informatik Pflichtpraktikum mit
Ausbildung, ich hab keine Ahnung
also insgesamt ist
mal 12 oder mal 14
ach 3 Monate
ja, scheiß drauf, mach das und gut ist
musst du es eh machen
ja, ich, keine Ahnung
weiß ich nicht, kann hier nichts dazu sagen
so
ja, ach ja
und das beste ist
ich hab abgenommen, auch seit ich das mache
wie gesagt, Spitzengewicht
war mal, sagen wir 109
runden wir auf
88,3
oder so
also
um, ungefähr 20 Kilo weniger
jetzt bin ich gar nicht mehr so
pipo fett wie davor
ich sitz zwar immer noch
ich sitz vielleicht jetzt, ok Leute
ich sitz jetzt nicht mal 16 Stunden vorm PC
an einem Homeoffice Tag, sondern nur noch
14 Stunden, aber immerhin
hab ich die anderen 2
Stunden was sinnvolles dann gemacht
und seitdem geht's mir echt besser
so, falls ihr irgendwelche Fragen übersehen habt, hau ab,
haut's einfach nochmal rein
ja
und wisst ihr was auch sehr motivierend
ist, wir machen gleich, ich wollte
Home Assistant Update machen, das könnte, siehste
das könnte ich jetzt machen, Home Assistant
Update in der Zeit
wo ich, wo ich laber
ähm
so, Settings
Update
ich brauch kein Backup installen
ja, was auch sehr motivierend
ist, es gibt Tage
also man lernt so mit der Zeit
so, um welche, um welche Uhrzeit
man am besten, am besten rennen kann
mittlerweile mach ich's ja auch so, dass ich oftmals vormittags
an Homeoffice Tagen meine, meine Joggingrunde
mach und nachmittags nochmal Fahrradfahren gehe
oder sowas, zumindest
was auch sehr motivierend ist, manchmal hat man
so Tage, da läuft's richtig gut, ja
heute zum Beispiel war so ein Tag
vormittags meine Runde gemacht
dann nochmal eine Runde gerannt und nachmittags nochmal Fahrrad
gefahren und heute hab ich's richtig
in den Beinen gemerkt, da ging richtig
gut was, ja
ich muss ein paar mal so ein paar richtig steile Anstiege
zu Brücken hochfahren
die ist immer nicht lang, so keine Ahnung 150 Meter
oder so, es geht dann aber klar
15% oder so hoch
und ähm
heute bin ich da richtig
richtig im Stehen
also hochge, hochgewiegetrittelt
ja, richtig volle Pulle
ohne, ohne dass mir die Beine abgefallen
sind danach, ja, so Tage sind immer nice
wenn, wenn du einfach merkst so
ey, heute, heute ist Druck dahinter
heute geht was
wie viele Kilometer läufst du meistens
dann circa, das hängt davon ab was
der Trainings, ich, ich nenn's jetzt mal Trainingsplan
auch wenn's ein App generierter Trainingsplan ist
das, das hängt davon ab was der Trainingsplan
sagt, da geht's nicht so unbedingt um Kilometer
sondern um Zeit und
ja, je nachdem wie schnell das vorgibt, also
das ist zwischen, das wird jetzt
nicht so viel helfen, das ist zwischen
4 und
12, je nachdem was
ansteht, also meine Lieblings
Runde ist knapp 6 Kilometer
die kann ich aber variieren
wenn ich ohne Plan
renne, manchmal ist es auch so, dass ich keinen Bock hab
auf das was die Uhr, beziehungsweise die App vorschlägt
dann renne ich einfach so
dann renne ich meistens diese
5, 5,5, 6 Kilometer
je nachdem ob man noch die eine
Kreuzung früher oder später rennt
zu meistens diese 6 Kilometer Runde
die geht hier quasi einmal am Main lang
dann über eine Brücke auf der anderen
Mainseite und dann wieder auf eine Brücke zurück
also das längste
was ich bisher gerannt bin waren glaube ich 14 Kilometer
das Update
ist jetzt schon fertig, warum ging das so schnell
Cake Weight Install
das längste was ich glaube ich
gelaufen bin waren 14 Kilometer
das ging erstaunlich gut, hätte ich selbst nicht gedacht
da hatte ich es aber nicht
da habe ich es aber nicht so übertrieben
wollte ich mal gucken
ob das geht
Max
macht Krafttraining, ich müsste
die, also das ist ja
auch wenn man sich da ein bisschen mit beschäftigt
es wird ja überall empfohlen
dass man zu Ausdauersachen
noch ein bisschen Muskel trainieren soll
gerade fürs Rennen
hat er immer gesagt so irgendwie
Core Strength bla, aber ich habe
keinen Bock, wobei ich es eigentlich
gut verbinden könnte mit
wenn ich nach Frankfurt
fahren fahre, dann time ich es ja
meistens so, dass ich dort
mit einem, also an dem gleichen Tag
hinfahre, wo ich
wo noch jemand
kommt, mit dem ich mich gut verstehe
und wir haben auch nicht weit in den Fitnessstudio
da könnte man das theoretisch zumindest einmal die Woche machen
aber ich habe keinen Bock, ich bin da
weiß ich
ich renne lieber für mich oder fahre lieber Fahrrad
für mich
ja das ist so, wenn man
ah das jetzt funktioniert mit dem Update oder nicht
ähm
das ist normal, wenn man nicht
geübt ist, also es ist bei mir auch so
also man darf nicht, man darf nicht
davon ausgehen, nur weil man jetzt regelmäßig rennt
kann man das jeden Tag immer volle Pulle machen
das funktioniert nicht
ah das jetzt funktioniert mit dem Update oder nicht
ob
ich restarte den nochmal, ich hoffe das
alles
klappt
ja also es ist wichtig, dass man
den Großteil seines
Ausdauertrainings tatsächlich
in einem Bereich macht
der nicht so anstrengend
ist, weil ansonsten tut dir permanent
irgendwas weh
und du hast auch größeres Verletzungs-
also am Anfang habe ich das beispielsweise komplett
planlos gemacht, da bin ich ja einfach meine
5-6 Kilometer Runde gerannt
immer so schnell, dass es schön anstrengend war
und dann habe ich einen Tag Pause
gemacht, dann bin ich weiter und irgendwann habe ich
festgestellt, dass das funktioniert einfach nicht
da tun dir die Waden weh, die tun dir das
Schienbein tut dir, fängt dir an weh zu tun
und alles, weil es ist einfach zu anstrengend
selbst wenn es nur jeden zweiten Tag ist
und es ist unterm Strich auch besser
man macht jeden Tag was
aber
70%
davon nicht so
dass es anfängt weh zu tun
da kannst du nämlich insgesamt
mehr machen
und du musst
nicht aufhören, weil dir das Bein weh tut
aber ich hatte das auch letztens
also
ich bin letztens
5,5
Kilometer gerannt, so schnell wie noch
nie vorher und
das war gar keine Absicht, ich habe mir einfach an dem Tag gedacht
ey guck mal hier, heute geht gut was
und danach habe ich es auch gemerkt, gerade am nächsten
Tag, da hat mir das Schienbein weh getan
und dann musste ich ein paar Tage
nur sehr, da habe ich
einen Tag Pause gemacht, danach bin ich noch einen Tag
nur Fahrrad gefahren, da musste ich dann auch einen weiteren
Tag nur sehr langsam laufen
also das funktioniert nicht
wenn man es übertreibt
dann tut einem das Bein weh
gerade wenn man pepo fett ist, wie ich
und wie viele von euch
wahrscheinlich auch, wenn man zu dick ist
dann geht das ja nochmal extra
aufs Schienbein
und auf die Waden und auf alles
so, hat das jetzt funktioniert mit dem Reboot?
nice, okay
guck mal hier, Addons
müssen wir da irgendwas aktualisieren?
gibt es da was zu aktualisieren?
Protection Moist ist mir wurscht
Zigbee...
warum ist denn das hier so hässlich da oben drüber?
aber du musst doch ewig
schlank sein, wenn du so viel rennst, ne bin ich nicht
ich war, ich habe
109 Kilo gewogen
108,5 Kilo
war 1,74, ich war also massive pepo fett
und jetzt wiege ich 88,3 Kilo
also ich habe schon ein bisschen was abgenommen
aber es ist nicht so, als nur weil du anfängst zu rennen
du auf einmal übelst dünn bist
zumindest, lange Rede
kurzer Sinn, ich bin
so fit mit knapp 40
wie noch nie vorher
Kalorien zählen ist doof, mache ich auch nicht
ja und beim Essen
mache ich immer noch den gleichen
Kram wie vorher, ich futter ungesundes
Zeug
wobei ich es insgesamt vielleicht
minimal
nicht mehr ganz so fettig
und ganz so übertrieben mache
wie früher
aber insgesamt ist es weit davon
entfernt wirklich so
empfohlene gesunde Ernährung zu sein
und seitdem ich mehr Sport mache
habe ich auch übertrieben Hunger
das gute daran ist
dass ich mir immer denke, ja
scheiß drauf, bist heute gerannt
bist Fahrrad gefahren, sonst wie jetzt wird halt erstmal
gefressen und gut ist
dann brauchst du ja auch, musst ja auch
irgendwie Muster Kram ja auch wieder rein
so, ZigBee Stick
Update ist durch, also
um das nochmal zusammen zu fassen
was ich probieren werde ist, ich habe mir so einen
ZigBee Dongle gekauft von Sonoff
ich hole den gerade mal und stecke den mal
in meinen Home Assistant
in meine Home Assistant vor allem rein
Gachi Bass
und den werden wir flashen
ne den stecke ich nicht in meinen Home Assistant rein
weil ich will den ja flashen, den muss ich hier rein
hier rein stecken
den werde ich jetzt flashen
mit einer neuen Firmware
und danach
verschwindet quasi alles was ZigBee ist
von dem Gerät
und er ist eine reine Antenne
im Endeffekt nur noch der Stick
und ZigBee muss dann in Software gemacht werden
auf dem Rechner
dafür kann der Stick dann von
mehreren Software Komponenten
gleichzeitig angesprochen werden
und so kann man
Thread Matter und ZigBee
zusammen machen
Thread-Matter
plus ZigBee mit dem gleichen Stick machen
heißt, wenn ich in Zukunft
mal Thread Geräte habe
dann kann ich die mit dem gleichen Stick
ansteuern, die ich auch für meine ZigBee
Geräte benutze
und das ist sehr nice, das wollte ich mal ausprobieren
Connect to Virtual Machine
Stream
schauen wir mal
ja da ist er
ACM 0
also ich habe mir dazu schon mal ein Video
angeguckt
so richtig zusammen kriege ich es aus dem Kopf
aber nicht
es gibt ein Github Projekt
mit USB Flasher
und mittlerweile
geht das wohl auch
ne ich habe das
bei ZigBee
to MQTT gelesen
genau hier
Supported Devices
äh Supported Devices
und dort gab es
irgendwo
ein
ne Recommended Devices
müssen wir gucken oder
Supported Adapters
nicht Supported Devices, Supported Adapters
so und da gab es ein Link
dazu
Sonoff E genau
Flasher
ja das hier
genau da hat nämlich jemand der
deutlich High IQiger ist als wir Chat
nämlich der Duxed
hat eine
Webseite gebaut
die über
wie auch immer das heißt
Browser USB
direkt
die neueste Firmware
die man braucht
auf den USB Stick flashen
also auf den ZigBee Stick flashen kann
Supported Devices ist unter anderem der hier
und das ist ja auch den den wir haben
man muss allerdings einen Browser verwenden
der die Web Serial API
unterstützt und das kann Firefox
nicht aber Chrome kann das hoffe ich
ja
Connect
da ist er hat er erkannt
so ich sollte da jetzt
theoretisch eine Auswahl kriegen mit Firmware
die aktuell drauf ist und dann
so einen Wizard welche Firmware ich drauf
flashen möchte
und da müssen wir jetzt nicht
die ZigBee Firmware nehmen
wobei man jetzt denkt das ist ein ZigBee
Stick
nein den muss man nicht mehr auseinander schrauben
vor dieser Seite musstest
du das machen
nein wir wollen nicht die ZigBee Firmware
upgraden wir wollen die Firmware ändern und zwar
so genau
das ist es
die Browser basieren doch alle auf Chromium
ne machen sie nicht nur unter
IOS
was laber ich denn
unter IOS basieren sie alle auf Safari
Firefox basiert nicht
auf Chrome
und auf Chrome ist auch nicht korrekt wie heißt das
ich glaub Blink oder?
ob Brave besser ist
also ich benutze Brave
ab und zu tatsächlich auf dem Iphone
wobei es da auch Safari ist
nicht mehr aber zum größten Teil ist es immer noch so
es muss nicht mehr so sein
aber es gibt glaub ich noch keinen Custom Browser für
der nicht Safari ist für IOS
so und
ich benutze Brave manchmal auf IOS
obwohl es Safari ist
weil der so
so Dinger kann wie
YouTube im Hintergrund abspielen
ich mein ich hab YouTube Premium
da brauch ich das nicht für aber
manche Webseiten lassen sich in Safari einfach nicht im Background
abspielen und das fuckt ab
ja leider ist Firefox alleine
und zumindest kann Firefox keine WebAPI
so was es jetzt für unterschiedliche
Firmware gibt ist das einmal was ich halt hier
gesagt hab man kann das ganze als ZigBee Stick
betreiben das ist ja eigentlich auch ein ZigBee Dongle
man kann das ganze als
reines Thread Gerät betreiben
oder man kann es als
Multipan RCP betreiben
fragt mich bitte nicht wofür das
steht zumindest ist das das was wir
haben wollen sollte irgendjemand
mal Custom Firmware für das Ding
programmieren kann man es auch da drüber flashen
also Multipan
RCP brauchen wir jetzt
ich mach das aus dem
Kopf von irgendeinem
Reddit Post und Video was ich mir
mal angeguckt hab
ich hoffe das passt
was ich da treibe wenn nicht müssen
wir kurz nochmal nachgucken
Installation Success
nice
ok also er ist jetzt geflasht
als
Multipan RCP 4.3.1
ja Can I Use
ist POG
bei Can I Use sieht man auch das Safari
kompletter Schrott ist
bei Safari ist so viel
nicht supported
Can I Use geht nur in
Chrome ja gut Edge ist Chrome
Opera ist Chrome
Firefox und Safari geht logischerweise
nicht
only Ding
schade eigentlich das es in
Firefox nicht geht gibt es denn
Web Serial API gibt es denn
Pläne das für
Firefox
Moment das gibt es es gibt ein Web Serial Addon
für Firefox
von Cuba2k2
7 Bewertungen 501
ah
It uses a native API
ja das ist ja unsinnig
seit gestern ist der Linux
Kernel endlich nice wieso gibt es
neues Rust Zeug
also mit ja das es mit
ein native Dings geht und so ist klar
aber das ist ja auch irgendwie
da kann ich einfach Chrome benutzen
ja
ja das ist das ist blöd das es
nicht in Firefox geht
nun ja wir haben das Ding jetzt geflasht
heißt im Endeffekt wir können das
detachen
und attachen
in unserem Home Assistant
so und wenn man jetzt schaut
jetzt weiß ich leider nicht mal wie es weiter geht
wir gehen jetzt in Home Assistant
und loggen uns
wir loggen uns mal auf dem Home Assistant ein
ich hab doch so ein Addon hier installiert
für Konsole
Konsolen Access 130 jawoll
Massive Secret Passwort
was
wie
es ist Moment Moment Moment
mein Passwort ist nicht 123456
es ist nur
123456789
ok alles klar
so sieht man hier irgendwie
ls
usb-t
hä wait a minute
ah Moment ich muss root werden glaube
äh nicht root
sollte das nicht eigentlich
jetzt irgendwas anzeigen
was das so ist und so
mach ich es hängst du ich kann
ein System mit den Informationen aus deinem Stream
infiltrieren
let's go Hackermans am
Start
ja meine IP
weißt ja 127.0.0.1
127.0.0.1
hat er jetzt den Stick erkannt oder nicht
gucken wir mal hier
def usb
äh
ne wie war das
def
ne bei
usb by id gibt es doch irgendwie
sowas
ne
wie war das nochmal usb
usb by id
linux
ach def
serial meldet sich der Krempel ok
def
serial by id
ja
ok der erkennt das Ding
funktionieren nach dem
Flash eigentlich noch die alten
Geräte
das ist ne gute Frage
also ich persönlich würde darauf tippen
dass die
out of the box erstmal nicht
funktionieren
weil der Stick jetzt ja kein
ZigBee Stick mehr ist da ist alles runter geflogen
was mit ZigBee zu tun hat
wenn man allerdings dann
den mit
dieser Software Komponente
verbindet die ZigBee macht
die glaub ich included ist in
ZigBee2MQTT und den gleichen
Network Key nimmt und die gleiche Mac
behält das Teil ja
dann gehen sie vielleicht wieder
da bin ich mir aber nicht ganz sicher
wo ist der USB Stick
das kopieren wir uns mal raus das brauchen wir auf jeden Fall
ich werde jetzt einfach mal
ZigBee2MQTT
installieren und gucken ob es funktioniert
wobei wir haben ZigBee2MQTT schon
schon drauf ne
ZigBee2MQTT
configuration
log is error no such device
ok also
wie funzt das jetzt das steht doch hier bestimmt
ne da brauche ich
da brauche ich irgendeinen Guide
wie hieß diese Firmware nochmal
äh Pan
irgendwas RC Dings
Multi Pan
Dongle E ist das so
ok
wir können auch mal ein Video gucken
Dongle E
ZigBee2MQTT
da musste man da braucht man noch irgendeinen
Zwischenschritt
ja haben wir gemacht
ne das geht nicht
das geht nicht wenn man das einfach
als Serial einträgt
weil das ja kein ZigBee Stick mehr ist
sondern weil das jetzt nur noch die Antenne ist
man muss irgendwo noch ne Software Komponente installieren
die
jetzt für einen ZigBee macht
dadurch das man
jetzt 2 Protokolle über den
Stick machen kann kann der Stick
kein ZigBee mehr
mit der Firmware du brauchst jetzt quasi
irgendeine ZigBee Implementierung
die den Stick quasi nur als Antenne
benutzt und
das muss dann ZigBee2MQTT benutzen
äh
ist hier in dem Video was drinne
ok skippen wir mal
äh
und was ist das
der Silicon Labs Universal Flasher
ne guck mal
wait a minute
was hat der hier am Start
der Silicon Labs Universal Flasher
des brauch ma net
wofür
wofür soll das da sein
ok Addons
addons gucken
addons hallo addons
store
Silicon Labs
Universal Flasher
addons flash based radios
by default is flash the firmware to use ZigBee
nö wollen wir nicht
aber das wollen wir haben hier
Silicon Labs Multi Protokoll
Multipass
das wollen wir haben
glaube ich
wenn ich mir das Video hier angucke
ja
exzellent
ok
das brauchen wir
weil das ist jetzt genau
das ist ein Addon
das hat jetzt eine Software Implementierung
für Thread und ZigBee
und benutzt den Stick
quasi nur als Antenne dafür
nur als Radio
also quasi als Low Level Funk Device
und
das was dieses Addon letztendlich bereitstellt
das kann man dann wiederum in
ZigBee2MQTT verwenden
hoffen wir mal das funktioniert alles
ja
this addon
this will restart the addon when it crashes
ja das ist vielleicht nicht verkehrt
configuration
der erkennt das automatisch
baudrate
was macht der hier im Video
ok der wählt den Stick raus
baudrate lässt er
hardware flow control
aus
automatically flash firmware
auch wenn er das anders
hat er gar nicht
ok
enable open thread border router
das bleibt alles so
ok
was ist das hier
OTBR
firewall
ok eingeschaltet lassen
200 steht in der Anleitung das hat er hier nicht
ich lasse es einfach mal default
show
show unused options
ok
Also ich würde sagen, das sieht gut aus.
Home Assistant, Local, Dings.
Also ich würde darauf tippen, das hat funktioniert.
So, und jetzt können wir ZigBee2MQTT konfigurieren.
Das ist nur die Frage.
Vielleicht hat er das auch in dem Video drin.
Wie das funzt.
ZHA.
Ne, ich will das nicht mit...
ZHA-Konfiguration anpassen.
Ja.
Ich will das mit...
Gibt es hier vielleicht noch was mit ZigBee2MQTT?
Ne, das hat er nicht, ne?
ZigBee...
Ich weiß nicht, was ich da eintragen soll.
ZigBee2MQTT.
Multipan.
Ach hier, er hat doch noch ein Video dazu.
Nicer Dude, ja.
Ja, ZigBee2MQTT, genau.
Okay, hier.
Da steht drin, ne.
Experimental.
EZSP muss da eingetragen werden.
Aber was muss in dem Addon eingetragen werden?
Wir followen der Sache hier mal.
Configuration.
Alles klar, das brauchen wir jetzt.
MQTT, bla bla.
Passwort, ja, ja.
Ja, aber da muss man doch auswählen, welchen Stick oder nicht.
Ach so, der sucht sich jetzt den Stick raus.
Das habe ich ja schon.
Das habe ich ja schon, das brauche ich nicht.
Okay.
Serial, man schreibt einfach nur rein.
Port.
Adapter.
EZSP.
Wobei, ne, das ist ja nicht der geflashte Stick.
Aber wie macht...
Okay, da bin ich jetzt zu...
Was muss ich denn da jetzt einstellen?
Documentation.
Ah.
MQTT.
To use ZigBee with ZHA-Configurator Interface.
Remember, copy hostname of the Addon.
Add.
Okay, wir suchen einfach mal nach sie.
SELabs Multiprotokoll.
ZigBee to MQTT.
Da muss es doch irgendeine Anleitung für geben.
Ja, das hat funktioniert.
Ah.
Hier.
Sieht man hier, was er eingestellt hat?
Ja.
Ja, man, irgendwo muss das doch stehen.
Ich vermute, man muss dort irgendwie die...
Aha.
Hier, sowas brauchen wir, genau.
Ja, das ist Mario Musik.
Sowas hier in der Richtung.
Core.
SELabs Multiprotokoll.
Irgendwie sowas brauchen wir.
Genau, sowas in der Richtung brauchen wir.
Mal danach suchen.
Okay.
Ja.
Ist da irgendein...
Beides Beispiel für...
Wie hieß denn der...
Wie hieß der Typ auf YouTube, den wir gerade hatten?
Der hat doch bestimmt noch ein Video mit beidem, oder?
Okay, aber anscheinend muss man das so machen.
Port, TCP, dann das hier.
Das probieren wir jetzt einfach mal aus, ob das funktioniert.
Also, wo ist unser...
Laufen tut das noch?
So, ZigBee to MQTT, Config, Port.
Tim, spammer nicht so viel rum.
So, Port.
So, ich hoffe, das tut jetzt.
Ich bin skeptisch.
Im Moment, ich muss doch da bestimmt noch die Protokollversion eintragen, oder?
Das habe ich noch gar nicht gemacht.
Da muss man doch garantiert noch...
Da nicht ein YouTube-Video zu.
Aha.
Hier gibt es ein Erklärungsvideo, okay.
Wo ist die ZigBee.M?
Ja, zeigt mir mal die Config.
Von einem ZigBee to MQTT.
Okay.
Das ist zwar auf Russisch, aber ist egal.
Wir können das sonst...
Ach, guck mal, das muss da rein.
EZSP.
ZHA?
Nee, ich bin großer ZigBee to MQTT-Fan.
Ich sehe keinen Grund.
EZSP muss da rein.
Deswegen...
Also, was muss man...
Adapter EZSP.
Lock.
Ja, Error failed.
Error failed, okay.
Adapter EZSP, oder?
EZSP.
Corlabs Multiprotokoll 999.
Save.
Restart.
Okay, brage, dass der Krempel jetzt funktioniert.
Äh, was?
Vielleicht soll ich mir das hier nochmal angucken, ob das...
Der andere Dude hatte mehr Ahnung davon.
Ähm, fuck, ich habe gedacht, dass das geht deutlich einfacher.
Ja, das...
Das hatten wir schon.
Aber da hat er keinen ZigBee to MQTT gehabt, oder?
Oder hat er noch ein Video mit noch...
Mit noch mal...
Ah!
Jawoll!
Der Dude hat alles hier.
Der hat alles am Start.
Okay.
Also, das ist ja wohl die falsche Config, oder?
Das ist doch die alte Config.
So, also.
TCP Core SELabs Multiprotokoll.
Das habe ich da doch auch drin stehen, oder?
Nicht?
Core minus SELabs minus Multiprotokoll 999.
Nein.
Adapter EZSP.
Ja, das war es wohl.
Oder auch nicht, weil das funktioniert nicht.
Wie sieht es bei den Options oben aus?
Ah, ist nichts dabei.
Ja, das scheint nicht zu funktionieren.
Warum nicht?
This Open Coordinator Backup Format.
Not for...
Ah!
Ich glaube, ich weiß, woran das liegt.
Weil ich schon mal einen alten Stick...
...in dem Add-on hatte.
Kann das sein, dass der versucht, meine Config von dem alten Stick zu laden...
...und ich deswegen einen Fehler kriege?
Das probieren wir mal.
Ich lösche mal alle Sachen von diesem Add-on.
Ich lösche mal alles, was von dem Add-on drauf ist hier.
Slash Add-on.
Ne, Slash Add-on.
Add-on?
Add-on Configs?
Ne, ah ja.
Wo ist denn das hier?
Slash?
Wo könnte das denn sein?
Home Assistant.
Home Assistant ZigBee2M QTT.
Ja, guck mal.
Da ist dieser...
Ja, der versucht von dem alten Stick, was ich da schon mal hatte, irgendwas zu importieren.
Okay, scheiß drauf.
Wir werden das Add-on jetzt einfach mal uninstallen.
Zack.
Und...
...jetzt den Ordner wegschmeißen.
Das ist vom Home Assistant selbst.
Okay, Add-ons.
ZigBee.
Install.
Okay.
Hoffen wir mal, dass das jetzt besser funktioniert.
Configuration.
Den Krempel wieder.
Save.
Der Rest ist Default.
Okay, Break a Time.
Das ist noch vom alten.
17 Uhr irgendetwas.
Ha!
Es funzt!
Der hat versucht alten Shit zu laden von meinem letzten USB-Stick.
Easy Clap.
Okay, sehr nice.
Jetzt müssen wir noch ein ZigBee-Gerät pairen, um zu gucken, ob alles funktioniert.
So, und jetzt habe ich eine kleine Überraschung für euch.
Wir probieren jetzt zwei Sachen aus.
Als erstes, ich muss mal kurz was futtern, nebenbei.
Als erstes pairen wir mal einen ganz normalen ZigBee-Button damit und gucken einfach, ob es funktioniert.
Und danach habe ich noch was, das wollte ich nämlich schon die ganze Weile ausprobieren.
Danach habe ich nämlich noch ein, wenn dieses Ding mal eine Ordnung, das ist leider alles auf Chinesisch da drauf.
Ja, ich habe noch so ein Xiaomi-Thermostat und die sind eigentlich Bluetooth.
Aber ich habe gesehen, es gibt auf GitHub eine Custom-Firmware, um die Dinger auf ZigBee umzuflashen.
Von Low Energy, Bluetooth.
Auf ZigBee.
Das geht aber auch nur, weil Bluetooth und ZigBee auf der gleichen Frequenz ist.
Dazu.
Da sollen die aber mehr...
Wie, die ziehen mit ZigBee mehr Strom?
Als mit Bluetooth? Wirklich?
Egal, ich habe das noch über.
Wir probieren es erstmal mit dem Knopf.
Wir probieren das erste Mal mit dem Button.
Das Ding ist, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob der Button nicht schon gepairt ist.
Ob ich den nicht schon mal gepairt habe.
Deswegen muss ich jetzt mal kurz gucken, wie man das Ding resettet.
Und dafür muss ich vorher mein Abendessen essen.
Und während ich mein Abendessen esse, lasst uns mal schnell irgendwas angucken.
Was haben wir denn hier noch?
Die gute Seele des Allersammels.
Katze Fritzi verlässt ihr Frauenschild mit den...
Na, das muss ich mir jetzt dann angucken.
Warum haben wir hier so viel Steve Ballmer?
Moment.
Steve.
Developers.
Das muss jetzt sein.
Ja.
Der ist so fertig, der Typ, Mann.
Was? Developers? Developers? Developers?
Alles klar.
Jetzt bin ich so krass motiviert.
Jetzt geht es weiter.
Was haben wir denn hier noch?
So schön ist es zu angucken.
Budget Homelab Tour.
Was Homelab tourt ihr denn?
Jawoll.
Wir gucken uns mal wieder an, was andere Leute bei sich im Keller stehen haben.
Der hat auch was.
Ne, der muss so bunt.
Das ist ein sehr schönes Rack, muss ich mal sagen.
Das gefällt mir.
Das ist schön klein.
RGB beleuchtet.
So wie das sein muss.
Eigentlich komplett unsinnig, dass es RGB beleuchtet ist.
Ja.
Ich futter mal schnell mein Müsli.
Was hat er denn am Start?
Was hat er denn da unten für eine fette Kiste am Start?
Ist das eine USV oder was?
Zumindest hat er einen Raspberry Pi im Rack.
Ich habe ein paar Harddrives dafür, also habe ich jetzt zwei 4TB, die in Raid 1 funktionieren, und ich habe einen 2TB Harddrive, der nur für...
Ach, das ist so eine 4AE Serverkiste oder was?
Ach, das ist das, was er uns da gezeigt hat.
Verstehe.
Das sieht erstaunlich nach dem Gehäuse aus, was ich auch mal eine Weile verwendet habe.
Was hat er denn da?
Das sieht sehr ähnlich aus zu dem, was man hier auf der Erde stehen sieht.
Hallo Leute.
Guck mal.
Man sieht leider nicht mehr so viel von.
Das sieht sehr ähnlich aus, auch von innen.
Ich spule mal ein bisschen vor, da ist nicht so viel.
Oh, Mikrotik-Enjoyer.
Den mag ich, den Kerl.
Der hat Plan.
Es ist ein O-Droid C2.
Es ist eine Raspberry Pi-Kopie mit einem 64-Bit-Arm-Prozessor.
Und ich denke...
Endlich mal einer, der nett mit dem ganzen Unify-Shit um die Ecke kommt.
...4 GB RAM.
We'll talk about that in a sec.
Finally, I've got a routerboard Mikrotik RB3011.
Ja, nice!
Das ist ein bisschen älter.
Wobei, der 3011, ist das nicht sogar eins mit WLAN drauf?
Ist das nicht?
Das dürfte...
10 mal Gigabit.
Okay.
Actually, I just have it set to show my WAN traffic.
But it's a nice little...
Übrigens, ich find's auch schön, dass er die ganzen kurzen 10-Zentimeter-Kabel da am Start hat.
I'm actually quite a fan of the UI.
The Winbox thing that it comes with is really solid, so I like it a lot.
And I'm just still getting used to it, but I basically figured it out now.
Yeah, and then just various terminations for things in my house.
Ich muss sagen, das Setup macht Sinn, was man bis jetzt gesehen hat.
Das ist nicht übertrieben.
Da liegt ein Raspberry Pi drin, den hab ich auch für den 3D-Drucker.
Ein normal gesizter MikroTik-Switch.
Eigentlich ein Router mit viel Switch-Ports.
Und ein bisschen...
Das ist echt mal was halbwegs Durchdachtes, in der Größenordnung, wo ich verstehe, warum man sowas daheim stehen hat.
Nicht die Amis, die drei Racks im Keller stehen haben, was irgendwie 2 Kilowatt im Idle verbraucht.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich zwei Patch-Patches habe.
Und auch schön gemacht mit den 10 cm.
Amen.
Aufhörer dienen.
kiste hat weiß man alles genau ja gut die amis nehmen auch eine säge und schneiden
noch in die wand das stimmt schon
mal einer was ich auch cool finde bei dem war einer der wert darauf legt dass die dinge einem
ordentlichen wechselrahmen sind das sind die rumschrauben muss wenn er die raus machen muss
ich habe ganz viele nachts bild schon gesehen auf youtube die das letztendlich einfach nur
in einem gehäuse drin haben und dann musste dann muss er ab stöpseln und rausziehen und so richtig
dumm wenn er sich ordentlich beschriftet hast findest du dann immer die platte
gescheit ist das kabelboden das kabelboden
da habe ich noch gelobt da habe ich noch gelobt entkommen mit juni feier um die ecke
ich meine es auch wenn ich das mikrofon immer hoch und runter klappen muss aber ich will das
nicht mal müsli hängen deswegen hört das manchmal bis zu hoch und runter klappen
da muss ich muss jetzt sagen so schlecht ist das juni feier zeug ja nicht wenn man da was hat
schon dass man schön über sich im haus verlegt alles ist weinert herr lasst die leute ist so
schlecht ist das nicht hat das auch eine weile bis sie mir dann zu sehr auf den sack gegangen
sind aber man kann das durchaus verwendet wenn hier ist von my way which is from my
ip-radar and this one is coming from my main pc
Familien
Dockter
unter and movies
der nächste stream ist ich möchte mal versuchen meine alten juni fics points müsste da glaube
sogar vier stück haben 1 used
paar pillen
tschuойt
Und ein Nano
Heißen die glaube ich
Die kann man OpenWRT flashen
Das werden wir auch mal ausprobieren
In einem der nächsten Streams
Das heißt, wenn ihr dabei sein wollt Leute
Hallo
Dann werden wir die Dinger flashen
Mit OpenWRT und mal gucken
Ob die mir damit besser gefallen
Als mit Unify
Benutzen werde ich sie nicht
Weil ich mit meinen aktuellen Nexus Points sehr zufrieden bin
Aber
Mir juckt es in den Fingern
Das auszuprobieren
Das ist übrigens
Genau der Way
Den Nexus Point nicht zu platzieren
Die Dinger sind für Decken
Montage gedacht
Ich gebe zu, machen sehr viele Leute nicht
Ich habe es auch nicht gemacht
Mittlerweile habe ich es gemacht
Mit den neuen Nexus Points
Man kann gucken
Wie Nexus Points platziert werden sollen
Meistens ist es bei Nexus Points
Kann man im Handbuch nachgucken
Beziehungsweise im Internet
Gibt es meistens so eine
Abstrahl
Hotspot Sheet
Da sieht man wie sich das
WLAN verteilt
Was für Nexus Points benutzt du?
Ich benutze zwei Ruckus Nexus Points
Ein R710 und ein R500 oder R610
Das ist auch nicht mehr die allerneueste Generation
Funktioniert aber wunderbar
Ich sollte dieses Kabinett erwähnen
Die Leute sind ein bisschen zu teuer
Ich will keine 2000 Euro für Nexus Points ausgeben
Ich hatte Probleme damit, aber es ist okay
Ihr werdet bemerken, dass ich das hier auf einem
Rädermat habe
Das ist für Isolation
Ja, wenn ich
Diesen Server installiert habe
Und ich die Harddrives in es
Die Hauptgrund, warum ich dieses Kabinett
zu Beginn bekommen wollte, ist
Um Geräusche zu eliminieren
Aber es hat es tatsächlich schlechter gemacht
Weil es sich klar macht
Innerhalb gibt es keine Isolation
Für die Harddrives
Und ich habe es zwei Wege gemacht
Also habe ich die Unterseite mit diesem Rädermat isoliert
Das ist tatsächlich für Waschmaschinen
Aber es hat nicht so gut funktioniert
Also musste ich es benutzen
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir es können
Deswegen habe ich eine Tür
Einen kleinen Miniraum für meinen Rack
Das ist zwar auch jetzt
Hier nebendran
Aber ich höre nichts davon
Es ist aber auch nicht super lauter
Drin oder so
Aber ich bin sehr empfindlich
Was so
Festplattengeraschel
Und Lüftergeräusche und so angeht
Wollte ich auch sagen
Ich bin wirklich angenehm überrascht
Ich habe ja zum ersten Mal
Hier einen PC jetzt mit Wasserkühlung
Seit einem Jahr am Start
Das Ding ist super leise
Und kühlt es
Fuck
Cool as fuck
Es ist ziemlich schwer zu sehen
Aber ich habe Orlex Mopads benutzt
Die nur für Studio-Module sind
Viel RPM hat er nur wenn er hochdreht
Die Monitor-Hörer
Es fliegt auf diese
Der Fall ist völlig von der Grunde aus
Also habe ich keine Anreiz
Vor dem Gebäude
Es ist total sauber
Die Badematte unter dem Rack
Brauche ich jetzt nicht mehr angucken
Ich habe nur ein paar von diesen
Anleitungen auf beide Seiten verwendet
Ich habe noch keinen Plan für diesen
Was ich tun könnte ist
Frigate installieren
Und wenn ich meine PoE-Kameras bekomme
Ich verwende das als mein NVR
Es ist eine tolle 12-Kamera
Mit 8 GB RAM und 256 GB SSD
Aber dann werde ich diesen 32 GB Kit installieren
Ich werde das auch filmen
Unter 32 GB macht man es heute nicht mehr
Ich werde es auf der Innenseite schauen
Wenn es Sodim-Slots gibt
Ich werde mich nicht töten
Aber es sollte okay sein
Wir werden es herausfinden
Ich bin wirklich beeindruckt
Mit diesem kleinen Computer
Es ist besser als die anderen Dell-Computer
Die ich in der Vergangenheit hatte
Wie ihr hier seht
Es gibt einen Tool-Less-Caddy
Für einen 3.5 Drive
Ich werde es wahrscheinlich nur mit 2.5
Wenn ich einen SSD einbauen werde
Ich habe gesehen, dass man
Mounting-Adapters hat
Mit 2 SSDs
Aber das ist cool
Das ist wie ein Tool-Less-Caddy
Das kann man einfach rausnehmen
Und das ist der Slim-Drive
Für DVDs und so weiter
Ich spule mal ein wenig vor
Ich werde es nicht wirklich brauchen
Ein M.2-Konnexion
Wenn ihr das hier seht
Das ist ein M.2-Konnexion
Aber wenn ihr das hier seht
Das ist wirklich nicht möglich
Zum victory
Man muss sagen
RGB-Installation
Ist ja noch
Auf ausbaubarem Niveau
Bleiben zwar keine
Typen
Diffusor
B sir
Und hardware
Armen
ist, dass du die RGB, also die einzelnen
LEDs nicht mehr siehst.
Es ist immer viel nicer.
Gucken wir uns den kurz noch an.
Ich habe mein Müsli zu zwei Drittel fertig.
Klar geht's weiter.
Okay, wir scrollen vor.
Nope.
Selbst wenn das Rack
forever lastet für ihn,
er wird das auf jeden Fall irgendwann mal umbauen.
Okay, was dann?
Das sieht ja auch noch halbwegs
reasonable aus und
nicht so over-engineert.
Chad, wie machen die das eigentlich alle?
Wir haben doch letztens wieder gelernt, dass du mindestens
drei verschiedene Kubernetes-Cluster daheim
brauchst, dass das Homelab homelabt.
Und dann
das Einzige, was du drauf betreibst,
natürlich ein Dashboard.
Ich glaube, das mag jeder,
der sowas daheim hat.
Homelab, right? You tinker and you learn.
So, when you see kind of like the excess
cable, a lot of these things, I'm trying to figure out
still their final position in the rack,
and I've been adding a few things over the last few
cables. So, I
like, instead of aesthetics,
actually terminate, makes it pretty
easy as they come in to then manage
you know...
Schau, Miep.
Temperatursensor, sehe ich das richtig?
Eigentlich eine ziemlich gute Idee.
...route them over to the different
switches that I have.
This top...
switch, one thing you kind of notice
difference between me and a lot of other
YouTubers, I don't have a lot of high-end
routing gear. I would, you know, unify is
fantastic, but for me, I really want to
show new Homelabbers how you can really
start out and get a lot of great
hardware that accomplishes your goals,
but that doesn't kill the budget. And so
I've grown...
...Switch ist aber auch schon 15 Jahre alt, oder?
Das ist alles der Klassiker.
...over time. So, up top is actually one of
the latest editions that we did. I've...
I might have had this in my last network
tour, but this is a TP-Link TL-SG2210MP.
This is an 8-port managed PoE switch.
So my requirements was I had two APs
around the house and a couple of cameras
that needed PoE power, and I also needed
the switch to be managed.
So ich mach PoE mit meinem MikroTik-Router.
Der hat fünf Ports, kann alle PoE,
und zwei davon werden aktuell benutzt.
Für PoE. Fertig. Ich hab keinen extra Switch.
Wenn man natürlich mehr braucht, klar, dann
irgendwann wird's auch zu viel.
So I was looking around, I knew I didn't
need a lot of ports, but I did need
management, I needed PoE. And if you guys
have looked at prices, that can get pretty
expensive pretty quick. We're looking at
PoE and a managed switch. So I went for
this TP-Link switch. It's been fantastic
so far. I've been running it for a few
years now. Rock solid. I have
not had any issues. And so you'll see,
this is where my routing comes in. It's
also right here, part of my home
assistant setup. I do have a
temperature monitor, just to monitor the
temps. It's actually been interesting in
this remodel, because we boxed this room
in. I have noticed in the wintertime
with the heater running, it is getting a
little warm, so I might have to figure
out a solution to keep this room warm.
Im Winter wird's warm, ich dachte im Sommer.
A little cooler. Also bei mir im
Raum wird's eindeutig im Sommer am wärmst.
Wobei, bei den Amis ist ja Klimaanlage
überall, oder? Vielleicht ja auch.
Das ist kein Raspberry Pi. Vom Layout her, oder?
Oh, das ist bestimmt so ein krummisches
SIMA-Board. Das ist bestimmt so ein krummisches
SIMA-Board. Oh, das ist bestimmt so ein krummisches
SIMA-Board. Oder sowas, wo die Amis draufstehen.
Wo ich den Sinn davon nicht checke.
Ja, das ist ein SIMA-Board. Ich verstehe den Sinn davon nicht.
Und was ich damit meine, ist, dass ihr bemerkt,
wenn ihr da hinten seht, auf der Seite
ist, weil ich die SIMA-Boards liebe,
weil sie einen PCI-Slot haben. Da ist eine
4-Port-Intel-Gigabit-Netzwerk-Karte
verbunden. Sieht doch mal ziemlich
gebastelt aus. Die Netzwerk-Karte
liegt im Prinzip einfach auf dem Metall
vom Server unten drunter. Ich weiß nicht,
ob das auf Dauer so eine gute Lösung ist,
ehrlich gesagt.
Prox ist eine VM. Ich leite PFS.
Das ist mein Haupt-Router und
Feuerwall. Und ich habe immer PFS geliebt.
Ich habe PFS seit Jahren genutzt,
seitdem ich Home-Labs angefangen habe.
Es hat also einfach viel Sinn gemacht, das
zu dieser Maschine zu bewegen, die immer
anläuft und wenig Home-Assistenten braucht.
Die zweite VM, die es läuft, ist Home-Assistent.
Mein Home-Assistent läuft auf meiner
Haupt-Maschine. Aber wie gesagt, wenn ich
Hard-Drives oder Upgrades oder
einen Down-Time brauche, ist mein Haus
sehr auf Home-Assistenten verlangt.
Oh, schau ich, das Müsli, das
macht echt satt.
Warum genau braucht Proxmox die Updates?
Das war mein PFSense-Router,
vor zwei Wochen, bevor wir
die Zima-Blade einbauen.
Die R210, das hier ist ein i3 mit 4.
Aber das ist mein Haupt-Maschine.
Oh ja, irgendeine APC-USV unten drunter,
die aber aus aussieht.
Das war meine Freude und Freude für Jahre.
Ich bin ein echter Glaubwürdiger in
wirklich startende Basics.
Da sieht man mal wieder, was ein Staubfilter bringt.
Starten klein und upgraden, wie es geht.
Also das ist meine Unraid-Maschine.
Diese Maschine habe ich, weißt du,
seit wahrscheinlich 7 bis 10 Jahren gearbeitet.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, als ich sie
erst zusammengebracht habe.
Es hat wahrscheinlich drei oder vier
verschiedene Motherboards und CPU-Kombos gesehen.
Der RAM ist definitiv geupgradiert.
Jetzt läuft es eine Ryzen 5 5600,
64 GB an Erinnerung. Es hat einen 10 GB RAM.
Ich habe eine 1060-Grafik-Karte drin.
Obwohl es ein Ryzen-System ist,
musste ich die GPU für Dinge wie
Plex, Unmanic, Blue Iris und so weiter hinzufügen.
Das ist also, wie diese Maschine konfiguriert wird.
Diese Rosewell-Maschine hat 15...
Die Grafikkarte durchreichen kannst du nur in einer VM.
Man kann wirklich den Stoff von der Konstruktion hier sehen.
Ich muss das wahrscheinlich entfernen.
Diese Maschine hat 15 Drive-Bays in der Vorderseite.
Also sind alle von ihnen verbreitet.
Wir haben also ca. 72 TB in dieser Maschine.
Und dann habe ich auch ein paar Pools von M.2-Drives
für Caching und für VMs und für Dockers.
Ich mache ein Video über all die Services,
die ich auf diesen verschiedenen Maschinen leite.
Das ist mehr eine physische Netzwerktour.
Aber ja, diese Maschine hat mich schon lange mitgebracht.
Und ich habe tatsächlich HBA-Karten im Hintergrund hinzugefügt,
um...
Ah, Hausbus-Adapter.
Okay.
Die englische Aussprache hat mich verwirrt.
Bei uns sagen die alle immer HBA.
... als die Drives aufgewachsen sind.
Ich hatte nicht immer 15 Drives.
Jetzt habe ich sie vollpopuliert.
Und ich habe die alten 4TB-Drives über die 12TB-Drives konvertiert.
Das hat mir ermöglicht, die Kapazität zu erhöhen,
ohne einen neuen Drive in die Maschine zu geben.
30 Minuten Laufzeit mit dieser ganzen Maschine.
Es scheint...
... oder wenn wir verlieren...
Nicht schlecht.
... die Kraft für alles.
Sie hat etwa 30 Minuten Laufzeit mit dieser ganzen Maschine.
Es scheint...
... wie...
Ist das aber alles relativ stromsparend.
Im Allgemeinen zieht diese Maschine über 220 Watt kontinuierlich.
Und so...
Das ist ja nichts im Vergleich zu den anderen Leuten,
die wir uns angeguckt haben.
Ganzes Rack, 230 Watt.
Idle, zum größten Teil natürlich.
Also mein Rack braucht unter 100 Watt Idle.
Aber da sind noch nicht so viele Rechner drin.
Das geht aber noch. Das ist ja noch zu verschmerzen.
... dass das hier für etwa 30 Minuten läuft.
Und dann behalte ich einen extra Harddrive auf der Hand.
Also gibt es einen extra 12 TB Harddrive,
in der Fall, dass etwas runter geht.
Ich habe einen Handhand.
Ich habe keine Plätze hier, um einen Hot-Spares zu haben.
Also sitzt es hier und ich weiß, dass, wenn ein Drive kratzt,
ich den Maschinen ausbauen und es automatisch verändern muss.
Um mein Haus herum habe ich auch etwa 8 Kameras.
Und ich habe eine Mischung...
Ich habe eine Mischung von Amcrest und anderen Brand-Kameras,
aber ich mag die Amcrest-Kameras wirklich sehr.
Wieder einmal, ich benutze Blue Iris als VM auf dieser Unrain-Maschine.
Also habe ich hier verschiedene Kameras,
an verschiedenen Stellen in meinem Haus.
Es zieht auch von der Türöffnung ein.
Und wir können sie alle in Blue Iris...
Wo hat er denn den Strom für die Kameras her?
Checkt ihr das?
Das müssten die wahrscheinlich einfach alles durch die Wand gelegt haben.
Gut, das ist so ein typisches Ami-Holzhaus.
Da ist das auch kein Ding.
Da hat man die Säge und da hast du ein Kabel da liegen.
...on der Unrain-Maschine.
Also habe ich eine Türöffnung.
Und wir können diese alle in Blue Iris und dann in Home Assistant.
Ihr seht, da ist eine andere Kamera auf der Kante.
Und für mich bin ich nur ein großer Fan,
diese Kameras in etwas wie Blue Iris zu holen,
wo ich...
Also das ist es wirklich.
Es gibt ein paar andere kleine Zwischen,
die durch das Haus verbreitet werden.
Das ist echt ein Setup.
Das kann ich irgendwie nachvollziehen noch, ja.
Das macht Sinn.
Was er da hat.
So.
Weiter geht's.
ZigBee-Stells.
Wir testen jetzt mal, ob wir ein ZigBee-Gerät pairen können.
Das Problem ist,
ich glaube, das ZigBee-Button war schon mal gepaert.
Ich muss jetzt mal nachgucken, wie man den resetten kann.
Und zwar ist das ein
Xiaomi ZigBee Wireless Switch.
Und zwar eine WXKG01LM.
Wie resettet man den?
Press and hold the reset button.
Boah, hat denn das Ding ein Reset-Button?
Ich glaube, wir brauchen mal das offizielle Handbuch davon.
Manual.
Schadensanzeige Reset-Öffnung.
Was?
Boah.
Tatsächlich.
Das hat da hinten ein Loch.
Was mache ich da jetzt?
Muss ich da jetzt mit irgendeiner Büroklammer oder so rein?
Alter, ich habe keine Büroklammer.
Ich habe eine Mini-Kabelbinder.
Vielleicht geht der auch.
Ah, ne, shit, der passt nicht.
Ah, ein Jumper-Kabel.
Jumper-Kabel, das könnte gehen.
Das Jumper-Kabel ist natürlich vorne.
Komplett mit Lötzinn voll.
Da geht nichts.
Ich hole mal ein anderes Jumper-Kabel.
Ja, sowas da. Perfekt.
Exzellentes Jumper-Kabel.
Gucken, ob das funktioniert damit.
Reset-Öffnung. Verbinden. Löschen.
Okay.
Ich probiere das jetzt mal aus.
Aha, es blinkt.
Okay, Moment, Moment, Leute.
Wo ist das hier?
Permit Join.
Ich halte es jetzt...
Hat das jetzt was gemacht?
Ne.
Ich halte den Reset-Knopf jetzt einfach auf 5 Sekunden gedrückt.
Mal gucken, was passiert.
Okay.
Hat nicht funktioniert.
Ja, gibt es da nicht irgendwie eine gescheite Anleitung für?
Mifunk-Schalter.
Ja, ich bräuchte...
Ich bräuchte da mal ein Handbuch von.
Ja, genau so sieht das aus.
Handbuch?
Ach, Mann.
Was hier?
Ah, ja. Sehr gut. Sehr gut.
Also.
China-Chinesen-Kram.
What?
What the f...
Press the switch reset button. The gateway is just...
Press and hold the reset button on the device for...
...plus, minus 5 seconds until the blue light starts blinking.
After this, the device will automatically join.
Ne.
Hat nicht funktioniert. Okay, Permit.
Ich probiere und mache das nochmal.
Das dumme ist, man kann den Reset-Button nicht drücken, ohne den gesamten Button zu drücken.
Ziemlich sakt.
Wie mache ich denn das jetzt?
Okay.
Hat das jetzt was gemacht?
Also Leute, ich bin da zu blöd für.
Eins, zwei...
...drei...
...vier...
...fünf.
Also es blinkt, aber...
Aha, jetzt, hä?
Ahhhh.
Das ist manchmal echt so ein Ding.
Bei den ZigBee-Geräten...
...das...
...ist immer so eine Glückssache auf das Funds.
Okay, aber das scheint funktioniert zu haben.
Wir haben den Button.
State.
Ja, haben wir es doch. State.
Action.
Sollte der jetzt nicht irgendwie anzeigen, wenn er gedrückt wird?
Ach, hier hat man es ja auch.
Hier sieht man es kurz.
Wenn man kurz drauf macht, macht er Klick.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn man in Logs guckt.
Ja.
Hold, Klick.
Okay. Funktioniert. Nice.
Also, ZigBee-Geräte tut.
Da können wir mal kurz bei devices schauen.
Wireless Switch, da ist er.
Action.
Ja.
Change to Single-Klick.
Double-Klick.
Juckt den nicht.
Triple-Klick.
Juckt den auch nicht, aber Hold juckt den bestimmt.
Okay, whatever.
Double-Klick. Ja, jetzt hat er kapiert.
Triple-Klick.
Quadruple-Klick.
Okay, mehr geht nicht.
Also, der Switch unterstützt Double-Klick.
Also, eins, zwei, drei, vierfach Klick.
Oder alternativ Holden.
Holden geht auch, ja.
Gut. Also, Switch tut ohne Probleme.
Sehr nice.
Damit könnte man jetzt Zeug triggern, aber ich habe ja nichts zum Triggern.
Zumindest sehen wir daran,
der eigentliche Versuch, der hat funktioniert.
Wir haben jetzt einen Stick, der macht ZigBee.
Allerdings könnte er auch Threat machen.
Wobei das, ha, ob er Threat machen könnte, weiß ich ja noch gar nicht.
Ich habe ja noch nichts installiert.
Was muss man jetzt für Threat installieren?
Das hat er doch bestimmt in seinem Video mit am Start, oder?
Open Threat Border Router.
Muss man installieren.
Geräte und Dienste.
Open Threat Border Router.
Wo hat er das gemacht?
Das war unter Integrations.
Nope.
Home Assistant, du glaubst, dass du das Richtige machen willst.
Machst du aber nicht.
Ach, guck mal, Threat.
Ist das schon da?
Moment.
Woher weiß der denn das?
Warum ist das einfach da?
Ich habe das nicht installiert.
Ach so.
Ah, das wurde wahrscheinlich auto-discovered mit diesem...
Findest du das kompliziert?
Ich finde das eigentlich ganz, ganz gut.
Ganz gut gemacht.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt ja auch nichts richtig offiziell so ported, das.
Configure.
Ja, easy.
Und jetzt?
Ich glaube...
Leute, ich glaube, das würde einfach...
Oh nein, liegt.
Leute, ich glaube, das würde jetzt einfach funktionieren, wenn ich Threat am Start habe.
Threat Devices.
Ich glaube, das würde einfach out of the box funktionieren.
Das ist einfach da.
Was macht er am Ende jetzt noch?
Meta Addon installieren.
Was ist das Meta Addon?
Was braucht man dafür?
Meta Server, okay.
Das können wir auch nochmal installieren.
Nicht das, was wir bräuchten.
Ist übrigens falsch.
Addon Store.
Oder wie der Frasier früher gesagt hat, es mettert nicht.
Ich habe jetzt kein Meta,
beziehungsweise Threat Gerät hier.
Meta können meine
WiFi-Steckdosen, glaube ich, aber
bringt mir nichts.
Ich habe keinerlei Threat Gerät hier.
Mir geht es bloß darum, dass ich dieses Setup
gerne so in Zukunft verwenden würde,
wenn ich mal Threat Geräte habe.
Dann habe ich keinen Bock, mein ZigBee Setup
über den Haufen zu schmeißen.
Annet Leach, du hast recht.
Das ist super versteckt in Home Assistant.
Aber die wichtigsten Sachen,
die du kennen musst, ist C drücken
im Web Interface
und dann diese Suche.
Du kannst Geräte suchen
oder direkt die Menüs.
Ich gehe überhaupt nicht mehr da drüber.
Ich gehe nur noch über diese Suche.
Und man muss da jetzt nichts auswählen.
Meta Server?
Config?
Wie, das war's jetzt?
Konfiguration für Meta erstellen.
Okay, wo ja.
Okay, let's go, start.
So, und jetzt müssen wir Integrations
und da Meta installieren.
Ja, das ist ja
easy gemacht, also da kann man sich jetzt echt nicht
beschweren.
Setup the Meta Integration with Meta.
Das ist aber sehr nett von euch, dass ihr das mit Meta
Stellt euch mal vor, die hätten das nicht mit Meta
Setuped.
Die Meta Integration.
Dann Meta, das wird wirklich nicht.
Ein Entry haben wir angeblich.
Ne, Fake News
haben wir gar nicht.
Ja, keine Device.
Ich glaube, das geht jetzt einfach.
Ich habe keine Meta und keine Threat Device,
um das auszuprobieren, aber ich würde vermuten,
das tut jetzt einfach. Wichtig ist nur,
dass dieses
Addon hier,
das da,
das sollte bitte
nie crashen,
weil dann ist Zigbee weg
und alle Geräte, die über Zigbee verbunden sind
und dann ist auch Threat weg und
alle Geräte, die über Threat verbunden sind.
Vielleicht sollte ich doch noch ein bisschen warten,
bis ich das live einsetze
und erstmal mein aktuelles Setup
weiter betreiben, so wie es jetzt ist.
Auf der anderen Seite, bei Home Assistant
ist es gefühlt alles irgendwie
experimental.
Insofern,
Chat, würdet ihr das
machen? Würdet ihr dieses Setup so jetzt schon einsetzen,
obwohl da überall experimental dransteht?
Es hat schon
seinen Charme.
Du kannst jetzt Zigbee weiterverwenden
und sollte wirklich Threat Meta
mal voll an den Start kommen
die nächsten Jahre, kannst du ohne an deinem
Setup was zu ändern und ohne den Stick zu tauschen,
zu flashen, irgendwie Geräte
neu zu pairen, einfach
Threat Geräte mit dabei hängen
und weiter deine Zigbee Geräte verwenden.
Das ist schon nice.
Wahrscheinlich werde ich das auch so machen.
So, und ob wir jetzt das hier
flashen, das muss ich mir nochmal angucken.
Zigbee Firmware.
Die normale?
Ja, das hier ist die normale Firmware.
Das ist die, mit der ich
aktuell alle meine
Thermostate laufen
habe. Wobei,
ich habe dem sogar mal
ein paar gegiftet,
gesponsert, wie heißt das,
für das Projekt zur Verfügung
gestellt, für neue
Revisionen.
Irgendjemand hatte doch diese Firmware mal genommen
und noch weiter verbessert.
Genau das habe ich gesucht.
Fanatics, ja.
Das habe ich gesucht.
Ja, Chatgear, genau das habe ich gesucht.
Ja. Ich habe halt auch eine Zigbee Version gemacht.
Okay, nice. Welche davon ist denn jetzt besser?
Ja, also
ich glaube, das hier habe ich
geflasht. Zigbee.
Guck mal, da ist die Zigbee Firmware
schon included, oder?
Two times less than in the
Version, okay.
14,6
Microampere.
Wenn es aber
24,7 an ist, dann
hält die Batterie trotzdem nicht so.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das
auf Zigbee flashen soll.
Weil, wie gesagt, die
BLE Firmware hat drei Jahre gehalten.
Und drei Jahre mit so einer
Knopfzelle.
Das ist schon krass.
Das Original
also das Gerät mit der Original
Firmware, das hält vielleicht ein Dreiviertel eher.
Ich glaube, wir flashen das
jetzt doch nicht.
Ich glaube, wir flashen das doch nicht
auf Zigbee jetzt.
Weil, wenn Zigbee wirklich so deutlich
mehr braucht.
Ach, guck mal hier.
Nice. Guck mal, die haben ja überall schon
Vergleiche. Poggers.
Custom Power,
Original Power. Okay.
Average Power Consumption
Original.
Moment.
Das ist die Original Firmware von
Xiaomi.
Oder seine Custom Firmware.
Ach so, versus BLE.
Ja, klar. Ja gut, hier sieht man es ja auch.
Also, der
hauptsächliche Verbrauch
liegt
hier, wie oft du Updates
sendest. Und ich glaube, ich sende
nur alle Viertelstunde oder alle 20 Minuten
Update. Deswegen hält das halt auch richtig
lang. Okay.
Average Power Consumption. Okay.
Guck hier.
Das ist kein Wunder. Schaut mal
hier. 31,75.
Das Ding braucht einfach
mal mehr als das Doppelte
an
Energie. Die Original Firmware.
So, und er hat den Reporting
Intervall eingestellt
auf, was ist denn das für alle
zweieinhalb Minuten oder so?
Zweieinhalb Minuten
fünf. Ja.
Oder irgendwie so.
Ach hier.
2,5 Sekunden
sogar.
Ja, ich hab das auf 15 Minuten
stehen.
Ups, falscher Knopf.
Ich hab das auf 15 Minuten
stehen. Ja, kein Wunder, dass das bei mir so lang hält.
Ich hab den Measure
Intervall hochgestellt und
ich hab die Advertising.
Ich mein, warum muss
ein Thermometer
alle 2,5 Sekunden
die Temperatur funken?
Alle 15 Minuten reicht.
Auf was
willst du da reagieren?
Also, wenn ich
sekundenweise mehrere
Gradsprünge im Bad hab, da ist schon
irgendwie, sind die Aliens
gelandet oder so bei mir im Klo.
Anders wüsste ich auch nicht, wie das funktionieren soll.
Ja, also, kein Wunder.
So, und die neue
hab ich gesehen, die neue
BLE Firmware, die
braucht ja ähnlich wenig.
Haben wir ja jetzt gesehen.
Die braucht ähnlich wenig.
Und wenn ich das weiterhin runterstelle
in den Advertisement Intervall,
ich glaube, ich glaube,
das können wir uns tatsächlich doch
doch geben, das
zu, zu installieren,
ha?
Releases.
So, wie flasht man diesen Krempel jetzt
nochmal? Da gab's doch auch so eine Webseite.
Hier.
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Warte mal, das, das, das
ging aus der VM wieder nicht,
weil man hier kein Bluetooth hat.
Oh!
Shit, Leute.
Ich glaube, wir können das doch nicht machen.
Ich hab letztens die Antennen
von meinem Rechner abgeschraubt
und ich weiß nicht, wo die sind.
Weil ich Bluetooth und WLAN
am Rechner nie verwende.
Die haben mir im Weg rum gebaumelt
dahinter.
Ähm, vielleicht kann ich die
Antenne vom ZigBee Stick nehmen.
Kein Raspberry Pi in der Nähe.
Doch.
Kann man das vom...
Moment.
Kann man das vom Handy ausmachen?
Ja, aber da seht ihr nix, wenn ich's vom Handy ausmache.
Ist doch auch blöd, oder?
Geht das? Moment, Moment, Moment. Geht das vom Handy?
Vom Handy geht? Okay. Chatge.
Dann seht ihr erst, wenn's
auftaucht.
Ähm...
Ja, dann seht ihr erst, wenn's auftaucht
in meinem...
ZigBee...
Ähm...
Unschluss. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Wie funktioniert denn dieser
komische Flasher überhaupt?
Ich hab das schon immer gemacht.
Der ist eine Alternative-Firmware.
Okay, das ist die, die mehr braucht.
ONF Programmer.
Okay, dann pack ich das Ding jetzt mal aus
und hoffe, dass ich's flashen kann
mit meinem iPhone.
Kommt dieses Gerätepopup vom Browser...
Ja, nee, das kommt... das kommt
eben nicht bei mir.
Auch nicht auf dem iPhone.
If you have a smartphone with BT...
Geht der Online-Flasher vielleicht
gar nicht auf dem... auf dem...
Moment, wie sieht denn das
richtig aus?
Wie würde es denn richtig aus? Ich mach mal Chrome auf.
Aber ich hab ja kein... ich hab ja kein...
Da sollte jetzt was
aufploppen, oder wie?
Moment, wir gucken uns mal ein YouTube-Video an.
Das zeigt doch bestimmt irgendjemand.
Ja, das ist der original
Firmware...
Enjoyer. Flaschen?
Ey, das funktioniert wieder nicht
vom iPhone aus wahrscheinlich.
Ja, fuck.
Das Popup kommt bei mir gar nicht
auf dem iPhone.
Ja, Safari kann das wahrscheinlich wieder nicht.
Mal gucken, ob da was...
Ich hol jetzt...
Ich hab unten...
Ne neues Android-Tablet
an der Wand hängen, aber das will ich
eigentlich nicht aus der Fassung raus machen.
Doch, ich hab Fire-Tablets,
aber die sind komplett outdated, die haben garantiert
keinen...
Die haben garantiert nicht das hier.
Sind Meta, Thread und ZigBee eigentlich
zu vergleichen? Du kannst
Thread und ZigBee
vergleichen, aber nicht so sehr
Meta. Also Meta ist ein Protokoll
oben drüber.
ZigBee und Thread sind mehr oder weniger Funktechnologien,
Mesh-Funktechnologien,
ZigBee hat noch ein bisschen mehr
oben drüber, was Geräteklassen und so
angeht, aber
Thread plus Meta
Thread ist das Protokoll
zum Geräte, Wireless-Mesh-
mäßig Geräte verbinden und
Meta ist
letztendlich oben drüber, das
um die Geräte
dann von ihrer Funktion her anzusprechen.
Das heißt, Meta
können auch WiFi-Geräte
oder theoretisch kann jedes Gerät
ein Meta-Gerät sein. Das muss kein
Thread-Gerät sein.
Thread ist quasi das Funk-Protokoll
und Meta ist so das Applikations-
Protokoll und ZigBee ist ja
eigentlich beides in einem
Bluetooth-Dongle. Ne, muss ich nicht.
Ich hab ja Bluetooth on
Board. Lass mich mal
kurz checken, ob das
Seite
auf iOS funktionieren sollte.
Was ist schlecht
an ZigBee? Nix. Aber irgendwie
sind die auf die Idee gekommen, dass man jetzt
ein Internet-Gerät
nutzen kann.
Ich bin skeptisch, ob Thread
jemals wirklich abhebt.
Meta auch so ein Ding.
Da wurde groß Wind gemacht
und viele große Hersteller sind dabei.
Aber so richtig
abgehoben ist das
noch gar nicht.
Also, ich setze
zum größten Teil
ich hab noch ein paar alte
Z-Wave-Geräte, zum größten Teil
also das, was nicht WiFi ist
und werde ich in Zukunft
auch machen. Es gibt eine riesengroße
Anzahl an ZigBee-Geräte und die wächst auch weiterhin.
Ich sehe selten
Threads und selten
Meta-Geräte dazu kommen.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich kann dir nicht sagen,
warum Thread angeblich besser ist, besser
sein soll als
Thread plus Meta.
Was hältst du vom Brave-Browser?
Ich benutze den manchmal
für Background-Play
und sowas.
Okay, Leute, das müssen wir
in dem nächsten Stream machen. Ich bin lost.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich werde mal gucken, dass ich Bluetooth
im nächsten Stream an den Start bringe.
Da können wir das Ding mal flashen und dann einbinden.
Ich habe gerade keine Möglichkeit,
das hier gescheit zu machen.
Ich hoffe,
euch hat es trotzdem gefallen.
Ich finde die Lösung cool,
dass man jetzt beides machen kann.
Ja, um das nochmal zu beantworten.
Das ist ja tatsächlich der Vorteil von der Variante,
die wir heute im Stream ausprobiert haben.
Du kannst über den gleichen Stick
ZigBee
weiterhin machen und
solltest du dir mal Thread-Geräte
kaufen, kannst du damit auch Thread-Geräte
verbinden. Ohne was an deinem
Setup zu ändern und ohne, dass du irgendwie
ZigBee-Probleme
bekommst. Wisst ihr, was mich
interessiert? Gibt es Custom-Firmware
für Samsung Galaxy
Tab A8?
Was ist da Custom-Firmware für?
Gibt es da irgendwie... Wie heißt
das jetzt? Die haben sich doch umbenannt.
Wie heißt
dieses... äh...
Lineage OS. Ja, genau.
Release
2019.
Okay, wie funktioniert das?
Okay, USB-Debugging. Easy.
Äh, was?
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
auf welcher Version ein Bootloader
mein Tablet ist.
Wahrscheinlich auf einer neueren, weil ich
das erst vor ein paar Monaten gekauft habe.
Ja, da mache ich halt keine
Custom-Firmware drauf. Scheiß drauf.
Die Originalfirmware funktioniert ja
auch, aber One UI ist so eklig
und so kacke.
Es ist nicht schlimm, es hängt an der Wand
und läuft ein Browser im Fullscreen, also
nicht wild, ja.
Aber USB-Stick rausziehen,
USB-Stick wieder in die
in die Packung, dass ich den auch wieder finde.
Ja, Chat-Gip.
Schön, dass ihr am Start wart.
Ich mache jetzt eine Runde MMO-Kreise.
Grind.
Wir hören uns. Nächster Stream.
In letzter Zeit war ich jetzt schon ein bisschen fleißiger,
was Streamen angeht.
Ich gebe mir Mühe, dass das so weitergeht.
Wem es gefallen hat, kann mir
ein Follow dalassen.
Und wir sehen uns. Bis dann.
C U.
Ach ja, und sorry, falls ich irgendwelche Subscribers
übersehen habe.
Ich glaube, es gab nicht so viele heute.
Münze, HSJohi,
euch habe ich gesehen, glaube ich.
Sonst gab es heute nichts.
Alles klar, bis dann. Macht's gut.
C U.